now calm down all right so I know we are
all right well we are recording so let
me count her down give me the 1 and so
my fingers not up here when you start
talking maybe a second after that all
right you ready
welcome everybody by the way before we
get going just want to say thank you
guys for all coming in and we're gonna
start our official recording here in
three two all right and we are laughs
welcome to the last word podcast with
ebon TISS oh what do we have in but I
can't find it is last by royalty we've
got the Red Queen thank you for joining
us today and you may not be used to
what's about to happen but kognito has a
thing that he does and honestly I just
got to pass it right back so do what you
do sir let's do it all right so welcome
to the last word episode number 67
that's another glorious Friday and we
back in front of the campfire for some
ludus shooter discussion I'm extremely
excited about our special guests so we
go get right into it I want to introduce
a lady whose affections positivity and
willingness to help others in our gaming
community is truly a sight to behold now
once she's impactful or bringing
streamers together but her love for
destiny and raid carries is a testament
to that fact
introducing the creator and host of the
Red Queen twitch channel member of the
screen team ascend and the last rites
gaming eSports in entertainment league
one half of the royal couple with Lords
second to last and by far the sassiest
stream on Twitch recently returning from
Bungie and kind enough to make her debut
within the realm of the last word my
girl lady Red Queen how you doing sis
I'm doing good how are you guys thank
you oh very excited
super also that have you of as a
pleasure meeting you at Guardian Carly
definitely one of our highlights I
believe we were talking about stream um
by gamma sub tree I believe that's what
the legendary meeting took place raking
them and and I saw you guys and I was
like let me go over here and talk to
them and try to sell them something I
ended up getting two flavors and because
I bought it late but man like I liked
actually gamer subs not like selling it
just literally from using it again con
cuz it was some flavors like overbearing
over sweet or anything like that and it
just tasted really clean I like the it
was just the light flavor but it was
just like just enough where it was
perfect so no I really enjoyed like I
was trying all their flavors making
combinations of stuff I think I did like
strawberry lemonade at one point which
was pretty good so no yeah that limited
one they had that's not official yet I'm
waiting on now and that was good yes
that's also one of my things I love
candy I can't wait for that to come out
see every but I love that dragon fruit
one that's just wasn't mine but
everybody else loves it man that dragon
fruit more power to you so that became
my least favorite now it's like
strawberry and watermelon but if I had
to choose if I had blue raspberry right
now everything else would be done
because my first garden con where I
actually met Ibanez I met those guys
like kind of earlier on and just
exceeded growth it's just tremendous and
good people so oh it's good to see you
associated with them
that's pretty awesome they got so many
big things planned I'm pretty excited so
little thing games suck yeah so been
actually using it on my own too so props
to gamers ups oh yeah I've been trying
to feel like pre-workout because there
was Jim
at the booth I forget his name but it
was really nice I talked it really cool
so I've been using it somewhat is like
pre-workout someone's just kind of like
for late streams it's been nice it's a
good balance and it's small enough you
can take what you want so not not trying
to start this thing a game for subs but
hey your partner gamers podcast right
the last word I'm not officially
sponsored but you know 8:1 by gamer subs
[Laughter]
my community his name's Daryl and he
bollocks if and tugs was really nice but
yeah I mean how was Guardian con for you
we had an absolute blast so we kind of
talked about our piece already but
little feedback from you just as you
kind of made that trip as well so and
this is my third year returning the
Guardian con and from like the first
year that I attended first year was like
pretty much a meet and greet they didn't
have a lot of booths and stuff second
year they had more boobs it was more it
was like more still more of a
meet-and-greet to me this year was the
first year that it actually felt really
like big and professional like real you
know just lots of booths lots of things
going on the place that they had at was
absolutely amazing I'm super excited to
get back the hotel was very cool
Rosie I was very happy with that but
there was so many artists there and it
was very nice to see that because
there's a lot of artists in the
communities yeah but I know they changed
her name but it's always gonna be
Guardian condom this has a special ring
in the air and with up being a destiny
player like I mean you know so I always
looked at it as someone said to me the
other day I can't remember who it was
but they were like you know kind of
guardians over the st. Jude kids you
know that's kind of what we are at
Guardians
looking out from
like taking care of a little lights
absolutely so absolutely yeah I enjoyed
it and I met a lot of people people I
didn't even have any idea knew who I was
it was like it was kind of a check for a
reality check for me
um I walked in you know standing in the
corner and then all sudden had people go
hey Queen and I'm like mmm and so I mean
it's uh it was a reality check for me
and last year last year I went I had
just started streaming I hadn't been
streaming that long jitney wasn't even
streaming destiny at that time I was
trimming Borderlands I met a bunch of
people mr. James work clawed a bunch of
people and become friends with them over
this past year and it was like when I
got home last year from Guardian Klein I
started streaming destiny and my my
Borderlands family stuck with me because
a lot of Borderlands players play
destiny and when I when I came back home
I told my Borderlands players I was like
hey uh do you guys mind if I show him
some destiny and then it was like BAM
destiny full-on and they stuck with me
and it was like my community just kept
growing and growing
it was nuts yeah because I know
sometimes you know communities can get a
little possessive I honestly like
whenever I talked to a couple of people
and my husband was like hey I'm thinking
about making the transition the destiny
for a while what do you think about this
and my husband was like I don't know I
don't know you know you're doing really
well I don't know if you need to do that
you know people are funny about their
games and I was like yeah but I have a
feeling that they'll stick with me
because a lot of people who came they
really didn't care what I what I played
they were there because of the community
and the interaction and the fun and so I
made the transition over to destiny and
I had made a lot of friends at a
guardian last year and they supported me
and it was like all of a sudden I just
want
to my community grow and I could have
done it I couldn't have done it without
without the support of a lot of people
so I'm very thankful to the streamer
friends that I met because they did
support the hell out of me and they gave
me a chance like we can't bring him back
like because I hadn't been in for years
we I went when it was destined Khan
that's when I met Cognito so that was
not the sweat bar but the year right
after at Tampa so I didn't do the first
one like the official but I went to the
first one in Tampa and yeah it's like we
were out there hanging out and stuff
like that and I was such a small channel
but I was like oh Guardian Khan is like
hell of Destiny been playing it and then
like I'd only been doing the YouTube
thing for not even don't even know if
it's like six months at that point oh so
really small and then now over the past
like couple of years things have grown
met people talked a lot of people had
guest on the podcast and so much more so
than when I went out there it was like
it was so much there it was more putting
faces than names but it was like having
conversations people that had talked
with on Twitter and like I honestly was
like for me as you said in the community
that's the biggest thing is like the
people sometimes I've asked the same
thing and you're just like hey what if I
played something else there like if you
turn on your stream I'm gonna come in
and that's the cool stuff it sounds like
you got an awesome community like that
they're like it's like hey if you want
to do something different cool it's like
we enjoy our destiny but you know you
want to go play something else and
that's an awesome thing for you to have
a really loyal community but it also
comes from you like the positivity and
stuff that you put out and that's why
Cognito is intro is very true cuz it's
just like your your passion and love for
your community and like just having a
good vibe in your chat and everything is
great so that's it's easy they they make
it easy you know like there's times that
I get home stream everybody has these
days there's time so you know what I'm
like I'm gonna bite everyone's you know
like and I get on there and I'm in a bad
mood and then all of a sudden they say
something crazy and Chad I'm like mad
right now
you know and it just puts me in such a
good mood so it's not just me that like
that you know brings off the positivity
they shoot it right back at me so
without them like I don't know how I got
lucky to get the community that I have
and it's constantly growing
I'm super thankful for that community
and they are they know this I tell them
every day before I log off you know
thank you so much for everything I'm
probably maybe I'm a little too
emotional like cry at the drop of a dime
like sweetspot dollars that's just how I
am there because like to me when people
do things like that for you you know be
thankful because people don't have to do
that like gifts and subs and doing all
kinds of other things like my community
is good to me they're very good to me
and I don't know what to say
like they just show up every day they
show up every day and no matter if I
I'll say I'm notorious for this so
they're probably gonna like slay me and
chat right now but I'm notorious for
this I will I will say all right guys
we're raiding on consoles today and I'll
get on my PC and I'm like um anybody
wanna play iron banner and they're like
oh my god here we go
just roll with it they don't give me
they'll give me crap about it but they
don't really they don't it doesn't
bother them there's they stick around
and they'll be like well whenever you
get ready you know so I've been trying
to do a lot more things offline with
them too so that's cool I can understand
which way you coming from like a smaller
channel myself in a monologue podcast
and it's like you said you really it's
the little things you really appreciate
that support you really appreciate you
know the loyal viewers and people who
donate and stuff like that cuz again
they didn't have to do it so it's just a
testament to you as a testament to that
infectious positivity that you bring and
keep up the good work indeed well um
sounds like you had a kind of a quick
journey to get where you're at obviously
you said if it was kind of last year
when things went but what about you when
it comes just to to play in video games
obviously you know you've been doing
that for a little while so what you know
what was kind of one of your first games
you started out what are you some of
your favorites over the course and kinda
what's your gaming history just to kinda
get your background see what you've been
playing before destiny became your kind
of thing so of course I mean the you
have been nostalgic ones like mario
super mario and all that Tetris and like
all of those things say
so as my aides don't judge me so but
what really like really captured my
heart I had an accident
when I lived in San Diego and I had a
very bad back injury I had a small
hairline crack in my back where it
completely completely snapped when I was
playing softball and so it put me in the
bed and when it put me in the bed my
daughter was like hey mom let me
introduce you the video games because I
was really down that I have been working
at the post office for 14 years and I
had always been like played volleyball
played softball co-ed all of those
things like just love doing it and then
when that happened it just kind of put
my life on hold and I was like what am I
gonna do like I can't get out of my bed
I'm miserable
you know I'm gaining weight like what
can I do to get my mind off things so my
daughter was like let me introduce you
to blackops2 I was like okay so I
started it I started playing it and
immediately I was so toxic I was the
queen I probably tea-bagged a lot more
than I should have been I joined a clan
and they were good like they were a good
clan and we had a lot of fun and that is
how I met miss sexy sparkles and Newbery
and when I met them we started playing
ghosts and then after we played ghosts
they they were like hey there's a new
game coming out it's called it's called
destiny one you should you should get
into it and I was like I'm not shooting
no aliens when I kill aliens they were
like come on just try it
we tried it first day we spent 30 hours
on the game and we were chat she said oh
yeah
and I know you guys know who Newberry is
if you watch if you follow PvP he is a
phenomenal player and so we started
playing together we started playing
trials together and I was hooked I was a
big trials planner anyone child player
we like to go flawless we like to do all
kinds of things like we were and we
would raid like during the week and then
but Fridays it was game face it was like
you know mine so we started playing
together uh towards the end of destiny
is where I discovered my husband on
Twitch so but but yeah so I mean my
first game black ops 2 that was my first
serious game I started playing
Borderlands in between all of that my
husband was like you should play board
early it's like no it's cartoons I know
and I'm such a game snob and then I'm
like oh my god this is so much fun so
Borderlands was like completely a whole
nother world for me because Borderlands
has one of the best storylines
yes played I have I did but a quick
story that is what actually got me into
Borland's cuz it helped me understand
the humor and the universe and then it
made me play Boylan's I was late to
Portland's but could you yes yeah so
border so I played that and um oh crap I
lost my train of thought but yeah Porter
Lance was amazing I enjoyed it I've
really really loved the storyline and
but but destinies kind of always been my
heart cuz that's when I really like me
and my sexy sparkles we've been friends
for almost nine years and that's a long
time to have a friend you know that you
met on the game I've met her in real
life
I mean I've met a lot of people in that
game so it's just kind of you know when
the Queen and the king oh we met what
was it drought like what was how did
this happen yes it was Charles I was
making fun of him um we okay so for
at the sass I'm playing
we're playing quick play me and miss
sexy sparkles another friend named Nikki
Newberry a couple of us were playing and
I'm like they're like talking to me
about twitch and I'm like yeah I'll go
check it out so I go in there and start
scrolling twitch whatever come across
his name and I was like and you know how
you can see a picture of the streamer
like before you go in or whatever I was
like oh he's cute I was like let me go
check him out so I go in there and I'm
like lurking and I'm like that's how I
tell him a sexy spark I'm like this guy
can get me in a lot of trouble and I was
like make me stay away from him I
started like slowly typing - I called
him dimples I still call him dimples
like because he had like these cute
little dimples you know why he was
smiling and playing and you know anyways
he was playing on they went flawless and
I'm like you're a really good player I
was like but my friend Miss sexy
sparkles is a phenomenal player because
back in Game one even now she's all like
a phenomenal player can I just your back
occasionally please Lord would she stay
out like her newberry together
phenomenal players and I so I'm like
have my friends mid sexy sparkles is a
really good player you should take her
with you said they went and I think they
were like one game away from Guam
flawless I think Wow and then he was
like well you should come join us
play so uh I handed up talking me into
it I wanted to played with him and Miss
XE sparkles and it was just like just a
spark yeah just it just went from there
oh that's awesome
yeah we didn't we kept it quiet for I
mean smart girls know about it but we we
kept it our relationship quiet for quite
a long time cuz when you're on Twitch um
you don't want to like you don't want to
mess up each other's communities and
stuff you want to make sure that it's
gonna work first before you jump right
into it and then you blow each other's
communities up cuz they're like but we
two together and you know it just
becomes messy so we took our time took
your time handle it responsibly that's
really cool just to see the game
bringing people together I'd be this
game again people could say anything I
want I know I'm biased because yes it's
my one of my favorite games but the the
it is tremendous what this community can
do and just to hear yours and you know
relationship wise and again obviously
witty bonta's as far as you know
starting this podcast and stuff like
that meeting him at accordion con and
stuff like that these are the stories we
like to hear
oh yeah but don't get it twisted like
keeping a crowd was hard cuz like I'm so
human at the end of the day cuz I'm like
having the lurk in his channel and stuff
and girls come in be like yeah thanks so
much I'll message and be like you better
ban her or I'm do you want me to take
care of it you want you to take man you
got that silent moderation in the
background all of a sudden just like
bye-bye you're Chet we're gonna keep the
people like you but not too much he's
cute again one more time I got the
hammer right here that was the hardest
part like that was but you know it's
which you're gonna have those people
have those people come in much Heather
you're so pretty about the game but
we're game in here and I'm taking it
all right strip just blow past that Lord
second-to-last yeah yeah where's he at
this morning taking off yeah the work
yeah he's military he's okay he had to
he's got to be at work this morning he
knows we salute him for his service
thank you sir yeah absolutely
seems like I mean yeah we
a couple times there when we were
passing by and yeah very very nice
gentleman there so you got a good one
and it all comes just so you ladies no
stocking does work you never know how
you like my wife and I is like meeting
story is just bananas to you so you
really never know how you're gonna meet
somebody and then it but if it clicks
that's awesome that you guys had it oh
yeah quick so that's one of the cool
things is when you knew it that early so
sparkles she always tells me he smells
so good every time she hugs him so now
I'm like when we were when we went to
Guardian Klein we were talking he's like
you know that everybody's gonna want to
hug me cuz sparkles tells everybody okay
and I was like don't make me go hide all
your clothes cuz I will right here I'm
gonna just you just spray him in too
much ass so they can't get too close
[Laughter]
Cologne segment he just wakes up and be
like you're like you just covered him in
perfume well thank you for joining us
thank you everybody in chat as well for
tuning in
sexy sparkles hopefully I never come
across you in PvP cuz I'm just gonna
shut that computer right down yeah yeah
that's not a good idea to play against
you so but yeah I just kind of wanted to
we got our background on you got to know
you a little bit but I did want to ask
since we got to very fanatical Osiris
trials people okay so we've talked about
this a little bit and I just kind of
wanted to get your thoughts on it as
well when would you obviously everybody
like it probably as soon as possible but
wouldn't you see it fitting and how
would you like to see it come back I
know of people some say like threes and
fours and all these other things like
how I like to see it come back because
that was actually a pretty important
piece of your world when you were
getting into destiny oh yeah so um so I
was like I would love to see Charles
come back soon I do I see it coming back
soon I do I I would like to see it come
back I would like to see it come back
as something different you know what I'm
saying so um I think I think that Bungie
has heard what everyone has said and I
think that they are working in the right
direction do not know what time one no I
mean nobody does I mean you know that's
that's just something I don't I don't
really so coming in to Dustin II - I
played a lot more PvE you know than PvP
this time just because Charles own away
so I wasn't I wasn't really playing PvP
anymore
so when Charles finally does come back
I'm gonna be probably be like one of
those terrible players but do I see it
coming back soon I think so because I
think I think they want to give us the
things that we want but I think they
want it to be right you know so
unfortunately I don't have any insider
information on that you know I just I
just really I really do see some I think
I see it coming back later but I think
that um I think if I had a choice in it
like if you if you were asking me and
you were saying hey Queen what would you
want I would want it to be something new
and fun I would want it to be called
something new I would want to brand new
and introduced to us you know and say
hey BAM this is this is something big
but I want it along the storyline of why
we why we went away from trials or
Osiris to something cooler you know what
I'm saying like yeah so I'm probably
gonna get like like a lot of hate for
that but but it is it is a new it's
something new you know it's something
new and it's something uh it's something
fresh because at the end of the day we
love our old stuff we love our nostalgia
but we also want something that we're
gonna be like what is this interesting
you know III is always something that
I've that I've enjoyed I know P I know a
lot of people like four before but 3v3
is something that I want and if I had if
I had my say in it I do not like
yeah I do not like I do not like capture
the flag or control or anything like
that I want just straight-up if you die
you die and maybe a little bit of a
timer to resort oaken's or I really
don't care about that part what I care
more about is the 3v3 fill because
here's the thing mm-hmm
when you have four before you have it's
like you can break off into twos and if
one person goes down on the other team
you know you can just automatically
collapse and boom it's done great 3v3 I
feel like I have a better I have better
odds like I can't tell you how many
times and in Indy one I went in there
was three left and and cleared the clear
the team yes a you feel like a monster
you feel like a beast you feel like oh
my god I'm powerful and there's been a
lot of times that I've watched new berry
and sparkles do the same thing or if say
one of their teammates is down two of
your teammates is down your verse and
two people
I just felt powerful yes I want that
feeling again and I know a lot of people
have gotten used to the four before and
that's that's fine but it's just not my
preference that's not what our war no I
want the 3v3 fill again and I want the
the I want to be powerful I won't feel
that way yes this guy had a bone to pick
with you after earlier he has something
to say he would like to come back in his
original form yeah ship shin beam you
know say like the whole motif en
powerful the city if he came back if he
came back and he had like a partner kind
of like a partner in crime and they
introduced it as something new but he
still was the person who was like oh god
the lord of
over everything that would be cool like
I like storylines I loved sorry life
can't be trials of Vance though you're
good that's good
they made Vance into of a fanboy there's
a kool-aid fanatic at this point he's
alright
we got we got break vans down because
I'm a very passionate I remember II
Vance was cool in the we cool he's safe
so in d1 like our saris it was like I
said it was d1 it's nostalgia it's that
feeling of home when it first started
you know what I'm saying so if they
brought it back I would be I would be
happy but I would also like to see
something new with it like give us a new
storyline give us a reason like oh great
got us here you could do like trials of
the infinite forest because he's at
right now he's got to get out of the
forest for you to talk to him because
that's where he's gonna show up when we
do things in his for is he he I think I
think I think like I said I think
they're heading in the right direction
they were super kind to me when I was
there and I think a lot of people are
gonna be super excited whenever shadow
keeps drops so next point perfectly so
not definitely never gonna ask you to
break an NDA for sure you got the
respect to go there and we we understand
that too but just wanted to kind of get
your overall feel of just your kind of
emotion when you left Bungie what is
your and I know you kind of said it but
what were your kind of feelings of were
there any like highs and lows like
feelings leaving therefore what we have
come and that you got to see because I
know you can say you think about it all
this Dayton I going to see them gave me
a new a newfound respect of who they are
as people they take their jobs very
seriously and they try so hard to listen
to the community and they try so hard to
accomplish the things that the community
wants I went there with an open mind and
an open heart and I was like you know
what when I get there I'm going to you
know have this experience with an open
mind open heart and I'm so glad I did
because when I walked out of there like
my heart felt full
happy so kudos to them on the hard work
that they do every day they created a
beautiful game for us to play we've been
playing it for a long time now and no
one else has been able to touch this
game to be honest with you as far as
character play and just how it feels
like sometimes I feel like I'm actually
in the game with my friends playing it
it's a beautiful game so they knocked it
out of the park on that like every game
there's always gonna be tweaks and
things that they can do better or things
that they can fix you know those are
just things that we that we just have to
be patient for but uh I do get I do get
that people have been waiting a long
time for a lot of things and I think
that they have the best entrance our
hearts they are just trying to make it
happen I got a couple of questions that
I get non-indian you can get in trouble
like I said so I just wanted to say like
two parts one the human element of being
selected right go like you you are
behind what I consider like you want a
sacred crown like this is my favorite
game one of my favorites you're like
what's that feeling to be there and then
just like overall you know I'm saying
like um he's talked about you know human
element again with how they're real
people how they're pass you just like
that whole thing in about being selected
yeah so it's really funny that you say
that because so many years I've been
watching people get selected and get
asked to go and I'm like oh my god they
deserve it they deserve it there's you
know that's awesome and I've always said
to myself never once did I say oh my god
I wish it was me that's never once what
I said what I did say to myself was one
day you will get selected if you keep
pushing and doing the things that you're
doing somebody is going to say hey you
know maybe we should bring Quinn
even though she's a little crazy and
she's probably gonna have some crazy ass
ideas oh maybe we should bring Qui Nhon
so I think I think what um what what got
me the most was the date those day that
I got notified that I was coming I was I
had strep throat and I was sick and I
was laying in bed and I woke up I heard
my phone ding woke up looked at my phone
and I
just went back to sleep again and it
didn't even dawn on me who had messaged
me no I woke up two hours later and my
eyes was like what and I went back and I
read it and I was like okay so I ran
into the stream room where a second was
and I stuck him right in his face
it was like and I'm already crying and
he's like you can't say no to this I was
like are you crying and I was like so of
course I ride him right away and I'm
like oh yeah this is happening you know
of course I'll come you know and so when
I when I first up my foot off the plane
like all through Guardian con I just had
that that nervous feeling in my stomach
like I know I know I met them there
everybody met them they're super kind
and stuff but you get you you're nervous
you know because one thing that I see in
the community sometimes is that the
community wants you to relay their
messages as well so not only did I feel
the pressure of having to say what I
would like to see in the game but I also
felt the pressure of what would the
community want as well so I kept that in
mind when I was in there you know it's
not just about what what I want you know
it's about what they want to and you
have to remember when you're going there
as a community member that they want to
hear what what you want to say but they
are they're also wanting to hear what
other people would say as well so you
know I when I went there I went there
with like a lot of stuff to talk about
so the whole Guardian kind experience I
was nervous and you know it as I knew as
a person who's newly partner and stuff
when my foot hit the soil on in Seattle
I was just like I immediately started to
sweating and
you know just at that morning ii
literally sat me on the side of the bed
and he was like you can do this because
it's a lot of pressure you know and I
know people don't they don't understand
that unless they're like in there in
that moment right like you don't want to
mess it up you want people to be like
hey Queen you did a great job represent
in the community but you also when you
get there you won't Bungie to say we're
really glad we picked her you know she's
helped us out you know so there's a lot
of things that come and come with that
so I was nervous but once I got there
they made it so easy they were so kind
to me and we had a really good time both
in the studio and out of the studio
that's one thing like when meeting them
at Guardian con like they were all
really awesome just to sit there and
talk to and they were really open to
talk for longer than I would have
expected cuz they could have been at the
bar or they could when sitting in places
and stuff like that and like if they had
the time they would they would talk to
you as long as typically you like you
would to they were really really awesome
about like yeah being there for their
community and they I mean I can only
imagine it was even better obviously
being in the studio but oh it was
awesome but it was also cool because we
had there was a couple of us who stream
there was a couple of us who was
strictly like uhm I think YouTube and
then there was a couple of us that don't
stream at all there was it was it was
good to see the dynamics like of
everyone that's different like
everyone's different point of views you
have your people who stream you have
your people who do the YouTube and then
you have the people who are off stream
who don't stream at all so it was really
cool to see everyone's difference of
opinions but we had a great group great
that's awesome see to hear things like
that because again you know in that to
anybody on the bus no other developer
stuff like that because sometimes some
of these things become a popularity come
true and then what I like is it seems
that based on what you're saying they're
picking passionate creators but also
from different genres not just one not
just a twitch guys or not yet just you
know the YouTube people or whatever
Chesapeake and the fact she even said
you know people who don't stream gives
me hope one day
it's one of those things that is like
that is so cool and we all love this
game and to have that opportunity like
you saying to have direct influence to
to be hands-on with developers I mean me
and II got a snippet of it you know at
Guardian column we were like blown away
just talking to people who create this
world you know I was talking to the
people create the raise talking the
beach all these developers are pin oh
man we talked to Penn oh yeah like I
mean damage and all these it's just
awesome people and they genuinely
passionate about this game so it really
really encouraged me when I hear your
story and you talk about it like this it
really really feels there was the two
people that I met that didn't stream
they were phenomenal and they looked big
and I do mean big destiny lore like
really big into destiny and it was
really nice to hear because they they
changed my mind about a lot of things
too you know like we would sit at dinner
and we would talk and these guys were
amazing so talking to them gave me a new
look on the game as well so it was
really interesting to see the different
dynamics in our group like it would it
was really it was a really good group
like we all like we left there as
friends you know it was really cool but
yeah I I enjoyed it but I think the most
part the person that I was most nervous
to meet was deej Wow yeah I believe that
every time he was the one that I was
like literally stuttering when I first
met because you know it's each Cosmo so
easy to talk to damage so easy to talk
to you indeed just really easy to talk
to you too but it's deeds you're like
okay so Cosmo and they're all nice
they're all kind every single one of
them but he was probably the one that I
was that I was most nervous at times
I've talked I've talked to Cosmo at
Guardian cons so I got those jitters all
the way to damage got those jitters all
the way and then and then I saw Dijon I
was like
[Laughter]
and trip over your own feet I'm like I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
miles I've been lucky to cross paths
with ya at e3 another thing it's very
passionate and they all are they're very
passionate about nothing very passionate
he's it's one of those things that and
then I was always tried to tell him when
I see him is that you know there's one
thing to be a community manager but he
has a gift at what he does just even on
even what avoiding questions against a
lot of that is a bastard
it's amazing his facial expressions are
even better because it was like yeah and
you're like does that what does that
mean yeah he's got a completely
collected he knows exactly what he's
doing he's he's on yeah all the time you
probably ever meet him
and it's like you're not gonna break him
like he is he is so like yeah it's like
you you know you know somebody like
torture or anything like that man he
would just hold a zombie like you're not
Deacon that breaking this guy is just
he's like I'll tell you whatever I want
to he's he's awesome so no it's like
nothing out of me it's all the basecode
do you have anything you can even
generally mention I know like people
have gone before and available to say
it's like hey we were able to ask
certain questions about this you can't
say what was said is there anything you
are able to or is it just completely
hands-off just thought of it yes the
destiny wall is beautiful the lobby is
great really cool beautiful you have
been trained now yeah that's that's cool
we like I said we definitely are gonna
get you in trouble I gained from me was
one of those things that always we know
you guys aren't Indian so what to me I
always try to preface it with feeling
right yeah so like coming in to shadow
key mmm
were you feeling I can say in comparison
to maybe you know all feeling like there
is going I'm going to do a lot a lot of
playing mmm sounds good oh are we
feeling all the way back are we feeling
oh I'm feeling strong oh we're feeling
like we're feeling like if Hulk man met
Godzilla oh that is hype is literally
over the rooftops at this point the hype
is over the rooftops hey if you're
positive about it that's I that is great
cuz honestly like we're already hyped I
mean we do this all the time so we talk
about and stuff well we've got a few
things I hit today but like I mean
there's a lot of things for me that I'm
looking forward to and there are certain
points like hey are more 2.0 excited
that I'm gonna stare at your camera be
like coming out you know new things that
they have coming out in a solstice oh my
gosh like I got one last non-indian yeah
okay oh so you know I'm gonna protect
you but technically last summit first of
all I love the fact he summit's
happening I guess not right last summit
from what we heard you know there was
some they presented some things and
people were very passionate right times
either the room was split or the room
was in unison like I remember story
saying like hey they showed you guys
something and the room in the consensus
of the group was like no don't you do
this
right and they pulled said thing back
came back the next day revamped my
question to you were we're there any
times the group was in disagreement on
something that was presented and then
maybe they came back or for the most
part with you guys all in the same
agreement and consensus with being
pleased is it are just a feeling in
agreement that's all I wanted is a I
don't think anybody left upset
okay I think everybody left with a very
very happy heart
okay okay okay we'll leave it alone yeah
well play we'll play this is not your
first rodeo I was like anybody out there
it's like we understand because if we
were in the same position I'd be like
like how was your trip yes like Robert
molar it's like I take your question
damn we need to hire a queen as a
dodging person she is on it like you
shake his hand and you get a little bit
of his magic for handling the media so
plus stuff Queen a plus
yeah we're honestly like really excited
we've talked about a lot of what we've
seen in the vitac and things i highly as
an RPG background player for world of
warcraft in diablo and stats and stuff
like armor 2.0 is like I cannot wait to
get my hands on all that stuff so that
for me and with solstice we get to
unlock our first set and we'll get to
that so that one's big would get teased
about the artifacts we've got stuff
about what's coming so big thing
obviously we got was the solstice of
heroes trailer so what we've got coming
we've got armor we've got armor sets we
cannot lock obviously do guys new
solstice last year can I go through the
whole process everything nice so it
seems like from what I've seen have been
data mines but general process of kind
of upgrading your armor everything like
that sort you guys feelings about what
we got coming with for one the armor
actually being like continually usable
into shadow keep yes thank you oh my
gosh that was amazing yes yes yes yes
absolutely
mmm absolutely so happy about that
but not only that like but it would even
make me happier it's like not only can
you continue using it but it look
[Applause]
look so good
yes like honestly I think shout out to
Paul Tessie again as well he's like well
they just introduced an armor set I
don't know if I'm ever gonna take it off
but it's definitely like I'm gonna be
wearing it for awhile and if those
ornaments go through as well oh no it's
confirm those don't let's go for 2.0 as
they say so you keep all of it you keep
your armor and you keep ornaments and
listen I just called myself like I want
to say a year ago no it's not a year oh
it's probably a couple of months ago
where I I said we were talking about
destiny one remember destiny one the
armors that you got that the glow the
glowing harm like some of the best stuff
if they bring this stuff out I would
groans so hard for it like I would grind
because at the end of the day your
in-game for your guardian is number one
and one of every one of her everything
is to have the best stuff do you have
the best-looking stuff do you have the
best-looking stuff with the best perks
you know and I feel like we are we are
going in the right direction and that's
you know that's what we're gonna be able
to do because look at all the things
that we have coming you know so this
armor 2.0 I think it's gonna be great
from what little bit of red and I think
I'm with Queen on this when I heard the
news I mean first of all solstice is
just always like the event I like to
talk process behind it like celebrating
and then just that whole weathered look
this pristine look and absolutely
phenomenal it looks shout out to the our
team I mean oh my gosh yes man they
continue you know I'm saying knock it
out the park
you know the cromoz the effects and um
like you said you know armor 2.0 was my
concern and you know about last solstice
we know what happened and it was just
one of those things was like man you
know it's a whole new armor system new
slot now this thing is gonna get put in
the vault you're never gonna use it
again and to see that come
Ford to see them get right ahead of it
and take that feedback is great and this
is something I'm hoping that continues
you know forward other futures yeah
because I mean look at even with crown
of sorrows like they're the armor was
beautiful the armor is gorgeous the
titan armor is just amazing but i feel
like in the Solstice like I love my
hunter my hunter is my baby and I think
the hunter and Titan armor looks amazing
but the Warlocks looks phenomenal you
know so you had the Titans armor for
sorrows that looked BAE now you have the
warlocks armor for solstice that looks
BAE all I gotta say is Bungie better
give me a damn good hunter set on the
next but yeah it looks really good like
I think that's the number one thing that
I've heard people say in the community
is how good the warlocks armor looks
like and it's funny how they just look
good they look really good and did you
guys see did you guys see on the on the
Solstice I read about the Solstice thing
where it was talking about the different
things that you can do like I think it
was what was it where the Titan has a
special the hunter has a special effect
and the warlock has a special effect the
solar void an arc you mean those things
yeah yes solar like The Guardian is
gonna emit a burning wave energy when
you pick at 30 orbs void you've got the
ability to go invisible and get
truesight and inability regeneration the
third one for arc is enhanced speed and
melee and sword damage so when you get
those 30 orbs depending on the daily
buff like you're gonna be able to change
it up so like they're gonna give you
some nice entertaining ways to play over
this next month yeah yeah which is good
because guess what you know that gives
us that gives us also a chance to see if
we like certain things okay like this we
get a chance to say once we've played it
we get a chance and Twitter is like your
number one like best friend you can say
you know oh my god I love this I love
this this is amazing this is something
that I've been looking for so I mean I
think it's a good way for us to be able
to voice back on what we like as well to
you absolutely and
the other day you want you want a
powerful Guardian your guardian to feel
like you know the end-all-be-all like
this is the Guardian absolutely
absolutely I did also we forgetting
about the UH what is it de se the
european european arial 'arial zone we
go zone it does I don't even know how
big it doesn't matter we actually get a
new zone with a free event for everybody
that's really really cool like new zone
to go to explore you got mini bosses to
fight the boss to kill treasure chest to
go find all the treasure chests hunting
thing when I read that I was like oh I
could I like doing stuff like that
I played ESO for a while and like you
just like hunting for treasure you know
so when I saw that part I was like oh ye
now long as they don't got a timer won't
said treasure that's what I'm wondering
they said there's a time in every fight
but I never thought of wolves did
something like that before did it ran
out so I'm just hoping they don't have
that but getting but I do like to look
over tress yeah I don't well I'm not a
big fan of timed either you know but I
mean if they do make it time can we have
enough time to know obviously that's
kind of what I would hope for too
because yeah if they spend time making
his own like I was I reached out to one
of the artists and asked him he's like
it was somebody else he got to polish it
up but it's like some somebody spent
time making that whole zone it's like
let us explore it there's a sandbox out
there we've got bosses to fight like the
time part I think is the mini bosses
where however many you get then you
fight the boss and however many minute
mini bosses you killed is how many
chests you gotta go search for him like
leave that open please cuz I'm I want to
explore what a go hunt behind the trees
like where are these things at I mean if
they just like line them up in the
middle that's kind of boring but if
there's all these little floating out
there it's like give me time to just go
explore and when I'm doing yeah I'm
peace out so I'm excited I'm excited for
all of that stuff I think the armor is
the biggest thing the armor and the
ornaments and stuff is and then the
little bitty tiny sparrow oh my god Oh
lost my mind when I saw that thing it is
so cute but it's that Shortbus sparrow
and i have to have one thing that i am
going to get that is happening that
sparrow is mine now these are direct
purchase right so we could direct one
second I won't be getting it because I'm
getting it I ain't kiddin I'm buying it
I'm gonna have it I saw that no I'm
looking at the pictures you got the
three little like Beach Coast which are
also hilarious the ones to the beach
ball in the one sunglass dude the
sheriff's bananas but you got okay so we
got like the wooden bullet Sparrow it's
like an Indiana Jones boat and then yeah
I'm like what is up with this little
baby like micromachines Farrow I'm like
oh my god love the fact they got to
tighten on it I owe ya big baby if you
guys like I don't know have you guys
ever seen the movie Employee of the
Month
it's what Dane Cook ooh yeah when he's
writing the tiny little like mini
motorcycle and he's trying to picture
little tiny mini motorcycle trying to
get there and this is your little mini
Sparrow to do the same thing I'm my
community so much with that little
sparrow like I'm going like it's like
with the chicken the chicken emote and
then the otter dance that was gonna
email yeah yeah so we're gonna have our
things that go through if you get all
three sets of legendary first if you get
the full set of legendary it will be
waiting for you in shadow keep which is
amazing absolutely you can log in and go
pick up a shadow keep like set like no
waiting just BAM armor 2.0 which I
cannot wait right obviously like I still
want to know more about armor because
honestly I'm curious of most of what is
sitting in my vault it's about to go in
the trash because I'm not sure how we're
gonna get the
since of life so I'm hoping that's one
of those things because I think legs
again follow up all test feels like he
wrote an article is like I really want
to know what's going on coming in the
future like the more we know sooner
because I'm sitting on like I have
enhanced roles here I have like you know
a sniper loader and sniper or scavenge
really I have some really prime roles
and I'm like do I break those down and
pull the mods out are they going to do
the old ones is just going in September
those are the questions that like and
I'm not asking you specifically like
that's the stuff I think a lot of the
community is like yeah - I'm just
waiting like I'm waiting for them to to
say what we need to do because I have I
but I'm a hoarder to you though so I'm
using my postmaster my other characters
I am at the full capacity all the time
that's that's why it cuz I like it
drives the community nuts when they seem
so even if they did come out and tell us
that we could get rid of it I would be
like what are you really gonna do
exactly are you really gonna believe
okay I don't think it's going anywhere
just because I'm a hoarder
you can delete everything I'd be like oh
yeah it's like I gotta understand the
system it's like yeah I gotta go and you
gotta find him in the future I was like
yeah I'm gonna hold onto some but it's
like at least some of those like
mid-level ones I like to have options of
like if I'm gonna go randomly use like I
had talked court kognito into pulling
out his crooked thing and I was like hey
let me go pull all my linear fusion
stuff out of my vault and slap it on so
it's like as good as possible and if
that is an option that I actually still
want to on do it for a little while I
might pick the more specialized roles
but then it's like once I understand the
system I have a feeling I'm gonna be
starting to break some of the stuff down
but until I know I'm sitting back hurts
so yeah that's something that I've been
just kind of waiting for it to you but
even if they I think even if they did
come out there with as bad as I am about
keeping stuff in my ball I'd still be
like
I don't think it would really matter to
me because I'm just like I'm keeping in
the new oh yeah I did that in d12 where
you keep all the overly old old guns
yeah I'm all charged didn't we I got
plenty of those I'm not hurting so I'm
fine what about getting more master work
course did you read that part on the
thing where they said they will see ya
first solstice they give you more master
of course what else did they say they
give you master workers materials
enhancement cores and a rare and
legendary gear so awesome yeah it's huge
yeah I think a lot of people need that I
do because I'm broke as a joke no now
you broke with cause back with me you
know there we go I mean I'm broke
yes oh yeah you know man enhancing
upgrading putting God rolls to get off
man those cause go they go they go fast
apparently I don't optimize enough but
yeah I have way too many cores so yeah I
get crap for it but we'll see hopefully
did you at least master work to go
figure you got oh yeah okay so you did
master one thing that you look oh no
like the ones that I like my hammer head
its master worked like no certain arms
that are fully master worked but I don't
do it too a lot because you can't do it
to exotics anyway I'll kind of move the
learning throughout yeah and then when
it comes to like legendaries and stuff
will make I've got so like whether if
I'm doing like my knight Florence and
stuff it's like what's the build what do
I need like how move suffer I don't live
in a loadout as much for PvE content
because absolutely don't so but no my go
figure like it is master worked and I
know cuz it's got 40,000 kills it's the
first thing I master worked so that's
okay so I'm proud of you did oh been
long long ago on now and that's I that's
my baby that wouldn't is not leaving my
side that's gonna be a hard one for me
to replace still yeah I don't have
Harley anything mister I don't master
right where it says so where are your
course way to cause going then and
infusing fuse everything is your entire
vault 750
or something like you're like I have 500
pieces for my hand they're all 750 I can
use of all that's why you have no cause
I don't know I my problem is is when you
like okay so this is something that I
would love to see come one day to
destiny I would love to be able to make
our characters more detailed because I'm
one of those people like I love fashion
and I like to make you look a certain
way so there's so many different outfits
that you can put on I know that's not
big to everybody we are you're here let
me tell you how bad I am just to cut you
would speak to my language right now
this is what he doesn't understand I get
crap on this podcast for this like you
gotta have your outfit for each subclass
too because you got a purple else
they've got a shaded you gotta upgrade
you know there's certain looks that are
very pristine so I understand your
struggle continued see that's what I'm
saying I just really like different
things like if I log on one day and I
feel like my garden
rough and ragged I'll put on rough and
ragged I feel like we're already looking
cute and like all proper and stuff I'll
do that and then if I feel like looking
funky I'll look funky like I have a
skittles Titan you know Titan and my
community hates it they know I don't
like Titans
we just lost connection with don't know
what happened dis was being weird colors
sorry I I'm learning how to tighten like
I mean I don't know I just I'm learning
how to tighten why I don't even know
what to do with that statement
I'm learning at a time it's like it's
not like you're learning to walk again
come on I'm doing better like I was a I
was a warlock mean and d1 now I'm a
hunter main and detail
my tie inside kind of been like nah no
[Laughter]
yo but I do have to get this because of
my community so oh yeah like Titan
tattoo so y-yeah Titan tattoo over the
other two
what how'd that come about because my
community knows I don't like Titans or
was it like a better way Jerusalem okay
so we did we raised $5,000 for st. Jude
awesome and to be able to hit that mark
I had to delete my hunter yes and get a
Titan tattoo I would have put the tattoo
on my butt cheek I would hit this is a
constant reminder well um I we it's just
a really special it's a really special
occasion to me because I watched my
family go through it when we lost my
brother he was 18 when he lost his life
to cancer so being able to have this on
my arm regardless if it's a Titan cuz
you know I mean I may give I may give my
family and my community crap about
Titans but at the end of the day they're
an amazing character you know and
they're they are a very strong character
and they are they've been a huge
character since g1 bubbles you know like
that way that was exactly so even though
I give my community crap about it at the
end of the day like I love all three of
the characters I just like to give my
Titan community a hard time but I really
do it means a lot so when I did st. Jude
I think the community knew how much it
meant to me and then me and ii did it
together and he ended up having he had a
warlock touch you he's now a warlock
mane and he Titan Titan main Wow
there we go I got one Titan out there
shadow to stand for that one
yeah but um at the end of the day it was
a wonderful charity I'm glad that we
raised that much money and I would have
done it all over again but this really
hurt on my wrist but what they go
through day to day inside the hospital
and stuff is nothing this is nothing
compared to what what they have to deal
with and the families have to deal with
every day so shout out the st. jude's
for everything that they do for the
children and for the families you know
it's just it's so heartwarming to see
the community raised as much more as
they did it was a lot of money and it's
gonna go towards a lot of really really
really really good things for families
and kids absolutely so when you were at
Guardian Conn did you actually go to
their booth and see that experience they
had I saw so so I still get a little
choked up I still get a little choked up
when I act I kind of see it away a
little bit cuz I still have that little
bit that's totally fair a little bit of
pain on my shoulder you know like you
know how it just sits there sometimes
that just remind you of you of what you
went through with your with yours and my
butt like kudos to him though cuz he was
a trooper to the end like he was such a
good person in every day he was just
like he had such a positive outlook on
life so I feel like if he was here today
he'd be like really proud of he says
that's awesome I was just gonna say he's
like not to try and dwell on or anything
but nobody when I did the experience for
st. Jude I almost was just gonna leave
the headset on even though it was almost
done cuz I about lost it in there I bet
I didn't like choked up in there and I
was like don't don't do it don't do it
no it was exist to watch and it was late
oh so no like everything the community
and that was why I guess Guardian Cohn
now she said whatever you want to call
it what is behind that thing the charity
working for st. Jude's and all the stuff
they do makes going to that convention
so much
I don't know it has amazing like warmth
behind it because of like just the love
for doing an amazing thing is what drove
it in the first place to be huge so
absolutely that's one of those things
for me when I just when I stepped inside
there I was like oh man so it give it a
little more realism to it and it was it
was amazing it's a lot of work and in
like I said them that kind of money
coming in for them is huge and um you
know I watched I watched my stepmom and
my dad uh you know and of course you
know all of the family just really just
um it was hard you know and you know
I've had I've had family members passed
from cancer I'm sure everybody has and
you know cancer is just terrible
it's a terrible thing you don't want
anyone to go through that you don't want
anyone to experience that so it's good
to know that there's programs like st.
Jude out there that do things for people
and help people because sometimes people
don't have other people they don't have
anyone they don't have a support system
and these guys these nurses and stuff
they're they are a support system for
people who need them you know and I went
through it probably about four years
three years ago four years ago I had
breast cancer scare where I had a lump
in my breast and we went and we we had
it checked out and stuff in me and that
those three weeks of waiting for the
bottle and stuff like I can't imagine
what it's like to be sat down and told
you know and it's just it you you go
through so much and kudos to the people
who do it alone every day you know I
couldn't imagine him doing it without
having the family that I had so the
these these charities and st. Jude and
stuff like that they they give someone
hope and they help and they give a
shoulder to the people who need it it's
a phenomenal and that's one of the
things very cool you know with this
community when you would be stories in
you know just a positivity and people
come together to that amount you know
what he's good causes and like you said
you know the mental aspect the human
element you know people need you know to
be confident need to be found others who
empathize with that situations
completely agree Queen especially for
those you know will suffer alone yeah
yeah yeah so did you bring didn't mean
to bring everything down guys wipe my
eyes here real fast remit people are
like driving right if they wants to
listen to this audio later they're
driving around like why are you guys
making me cry right now that is one of
those things about this community that
has been amazing it does hit you in the
field sometimes and it's where humans
were real it's like it's it's okay to do
that so yeah you're right I think I
think that's probably one of the reasons
why I think a lot of people can really
relate and this is really good because I
get to see this out of you guys as well
like I I think at the end of the day
when people come into your community
they just want someone to relate to they
want someone that they can identify with
and talk to and um when you get in your
feelings you know people they understand
and they it puts them in their feelings
and also that shows hey they're human
you know they're not just streamers
they're actually human you know they
have feelings and emotions and so one
thing I always do and I know this drives
my mods crazy in my channel on Sirius is
every follow that comes across my stream
I think I'm you do that every single one
every person that talks to me in my chat
if I miss him I'll try to catch them or
I'll say hey if I miss you guys I was
busy please say hello to me again
and the reason being is because I the
other day people just want to be talked
to they just would be acknowledged they
just want to be hurried
give them
chance to feel like they're interacting
and feel like they're a part of your
community in your stream they're gonna
come back and they're gonna become
someone in your community who is
positive and awesome in a big you know
pillar of that community and that's one
thing that I got right with my mods
they're not just my mods they're my
friends they're my family you know and
they keep my top flowing and safe and
you know and then in return it makes
other people feel safe to talk you know
people all the time he's like hey I'm a
longtime lurker I don't really say a lot
but I just love it here cuz it's just so
good so yeah I think at the end of the
day people just want to be they just
want to be heard
absolutely up you hit the nail on the
head Quinn I mean this yeah my podcast
you know when I started and you know as
I would listen other people and I'm huge
fans and um don't get me wrong like I
understand you know people get big to
sit there and talk to a lot of people
taken but it is something to be said
when you acknowledge someone right and
because you don't realize how much
effect you have on someone's day when
you know just by shouting that person
hour just you know image it is such a
tremendous thing that is I cannot be
understated and I'm glad you said that
because that's something I try to do and
you'd be surprised people you don't say
hey you know you know and they just it
just uplifts the energy and it's alumni
that's just it too because the thing
about it is when I got into when I got
in touch me man I told people I was like
I don't I you know I want to make
friends with everyone and by everyone I
mean you have your your bigger streamers
and you have your smaller streamers and
your smaller streamers when you when
you're growing you have to bring them up
with you because they've loved and
supported you from the beginning they've
been that that foundation of your
community and that's the reason why I
got the stream team going that I got
because I wanted people to you know I
wanted to show all of my all of my
community and my friends that haven't
supported me from the beginning hey this
is this is in return something that I'm
gonna do for you I want to support you I
want you to grow I want to
do you prosper you know and I truly mean
that like I don't care like I mean
people they come in I shout them out
you know there's a lot of people who
don't like shouting people out they
don't know a lot of people who don't
like raiding other people because
they're afraid that they're gonna lose
their numbers I mean I guess what if
someone wants to go watch my best friend
over me why should I be upset because I
have reference of streamers to you know
I I I am the same as everyone else
so at the end of the day if that person
chooses to go watch someone that
supported me you damn right I'm gonna
support that you know and that's just
how I am I know that I know that a lot
of people think that you have to network
with the bigger streamers just to be
able to get to get big but I'm here to
tell you that you can network with both
because you're small streamers are just
as important as your large stream okay
bridge with you you know like show them
love be be their support system as well
because a lot of times at the end the
day when you care about other people's
communities they're gonna care about
yours
on fire but I mean that's literally why
I was like when we were just kind of you
know if you watch any of your streams
like any vod's anything like that it's
exactly what you just described
positivity calling everybody out just
being a good human like hanging out with
them just just being there with them
being bar the community yeah I'm playing
but I'm with the community calling out
hey thanks for the follow you're like
I'm not too big to call it a follow it
you're like yeah of course they're like
people like some people just only do
subs and stuff and it's like sighs but
if you you make the effort then and
that's what shows that's why your
community is as passionate as it is so
yeah you through yeah don't be jealous
because if the thing about it is at the
end of the day like my friends so when
I'm streaming I can see my friends on
the left side you know and I I see how
they're doing and what how their days
are going and I'll and I always tell
them and they can tell you this too man
you're killing it keep killing it you're
doing phenomenal you know I don't know
how many times I've told James like me
and James we have a lot of the same
community and James has been on fire and
I just tell it I'm like dude
keep killing it you know you have to be
you have to be happy for your friends as
well to like especially when when you
are in this business you know it is so
easy to become that better so jealous
you're like at the end of the day like
kick ass you know do a good job and not
that's that's what I love about my
friends do it's because they're not
there the same way with me like never
once did I have anyone treat me any
different when I grew like well they all
treated me the same preaching it and I'm
glad you said that because that's
literally how I felt when II got to DCP
yeah he was a DCP and I was just I was
like proud I was like but it did yes I
am going to support him in the biggest
thing when I saw the artistic thing made
I'm like yo this is so cool to see
because I've seen his journey I mean
when you know and this years ago but I
can't tell them bro keep killing it you
are doing a phenomenal job and I just
love to see the journey so mushy listen
I've said that to your face I'm saying I
want to be my say anything I've said you
I broke keep it up cuz that kind of
stuff you'd be surprised that pushes
people and then also people get to see
where you came from and you repeat the
same like like we're the same yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying the to have those
opportunities is a blessed opportunity
and I think sometimes sometimes people
lose sight of the little things that
happen in life and sometimes they forget
to say thank you for the little things
and that's one of the things that I've
always tried to remember because there's
times that my mods still with me and I'm
like a monster you know like I've had a
bad day or something like you really be
in you know so I they called me out on
it and I'm glad they do like I'm glad
they they say Queen
though I mean at the end of day surround
yourself with positive people honest
friends because you need them to tell
you when you're being that way oh yeah
so yeah DCP was when I did my face
reveal as well because I'd been I did
like really yep yeah so that was the
first time cuz I got to a point where
well one video went crazy so things were
kind of growing I was like hey if I get
to this point blew past that point
thanks to you know stars aligning and
God shining on things but and then it
was like I literally had reached out to
ash the artist for DCP and all I said to
her was like hey and just her messes
were up in a sinner DM I was just like
hey you do awesome work great job keep
crush didn't love to see those and left
it at that and she she literally
responded back and was just like hey
awesome you do great work love your
content as well and I'm like excuse me
yeah so like those most she's awesome so
yeah I got to see the Christmas episode
so if I'll actually get to see her on
there too though go but know when she
came back like me and like cheetahs my
theme and stuff like that and she would
the half armor and half B and like so
goki can't change it I'm like I'm biased
towards that pretty split down the
middle and it was almost like a chrome
cheetah I feel like Alice Leviathan who
I have my full cheetah armor face and
then I have the whole my face she gave
me all three so yeah that was really
really cool but no as you're saying it's
late yeah seriously like that was kind
of think to a guardian Connors like the
talent of the artists out there I'm just
like I want to buy all their I have like
seven pieces of art that alone Brian my
Mongoose oh my god Marcus he's good
gamma trap is amazing I got NAMM and
necks nobody I probably say it wrong but
hers I got I got a little bit of quite a
few that I could like get my hands on
that kind of fit with I wanted one of
each character and stuff like that so I
was missing I was messing with Khan in
Anubis a guardian kind yeah I walked
other booths
like oh my god I'm a big fan I'm such a
big fan they're like oh my god Queens
stop it right now like yelling and
screaming and I took crazy con did I
part of my emotes and then Jojo did the
other part and then I also had a sword
who did some of my some of my emotes and
then I had Anubis who's doing my rebrand
right now nice he did my business card
so when I was at yep yeah he's such a
him him and Khan are really easy to work
with Jojo is amazing like they they all
every single one of them that I
mentioned so Jojo Khan Anubis all
phenomenal just so they make it easy so
oh yeah I was like no that we have
that's the Destiny community is is like
none other
mm-hmm and I've and whether it's the
community whether it's on Twitch whether
it's the artists you meet whether it's
the people that walk up to you at
Guardian Khan everybody in this
community has been amazing and the ones
who are toxic are not pleasant like they
don't make it because that's not what
the community wants and I think that
it's the positive positivity like you
like I mean you have like snaps doing
her panels out there like just we're
talking about mental health and
streamers I mean panels that you don't
even think about and you got people from
the testing can bring that stuff like to
light and helping people it's it's been
so awesome to watch so it's like it's
it's been a game but it's been so much
more than that
absolutely it's really true cuz I I so
one of the things that I make a point of
is I try to every night and even if I
can't I'll try to like put more time
into it the next night where I go in and
I hit the Browse button and I go into
the Destiny community and I try to
scroll from top to bottom because you
have so many new content creators that
are coming in and I'm like okay so let's
see who's new tonight let's see if we
can watch someone new tonight and just
hang out with them and watch them and
stuff and the reason being is because
the community is starting to grow like
wildfire
become very like flourishing with new
content creators and on top of that I've
met a lot of the bigger content creators
that I didn't get to meet before and my
favorite thing is going in I love
watching PvP I love watching PvE doesn't
matter what they're doing I also go and
watch sometimes I talk sometimes I don't
it just depends on what I'm feeling like
at the moment but uh yeah I do I that's
I've met a lot a lot of new people by
doing that and in return I'll see them
pop up and be like a queen and I'm like
oh my gosh I don't give them a shout out
because I've been in there
I've watched their content I enjoyed
their content but also you know
sometimes sometimes you have to give
back a little bit to like I said before
and I want to know my destiny community
and that includes the new content
creators that are coming in like you
want to get to know everyone and be the
master shot at your house Wien helped me
get where I am today
yeah so destiny podcast laughs just
living life over here but yeah I mean
it's like we're we're wrapping up here -
the summer is coming to a close Guardian
cons are wrapping up we're leading into
shadow keep season of opulence kicked it
off well like everything seems to be
like climbing up that like rollercoaster
thing so we can just hold on for the
ride a shadow keep into next year and
honestly what we got coming is we've got
the moon so right I know everybody's
really pumped about that they go through
I mean they've like relit the entire
area it's twice as big we've got shadow
keep we've got floating bodies that
everybody seems to have so many theories
about so for shadow keep since we've got
you here what and you just have to
compartmentalize what happened over the
past weekend like what are you because I
know for me I've what I know what I'm
looking for what are you specifically
like looking forward to in shadow keep
from what's been announced so far what
do you look honestly exploring the moon
like so when I saw the video that they
put out of where the developers was
talking about how they went back and
redid some of the things on the moon
and stuff I was like wow like look at
the scenery look at you know it looks
bigger but not only that just to be able
to explore it and see if it's still the
same as that was before or what's
different on it you know what I'm saying
like they I know they say that's
different but you still have those like
I said and installed your things where
you're like I wonder if this is still
here I wonder if this is still here so
I'm good I'm looking forward to being
able to explore it and see what's there
and you know just I mean honestly what's
what's the one thing that everybody
loves to do whenever new content comes
out we like to find all of the cool
things you know like what's hidden and
stuff like that so I'm I'm definitely
probably gonna spend a lot of time on
the moon just looking around and
enjoying the scenery but also I'm
excited to explore and see what because
you know Bungie is notorious for hiding
things oh look it's a glass you know you
always want to be the first person to
discover things and be like you know so
I think that's what I'm looking forward
to is the the just being able to see if
you know what's new and what's not and
see what we can find very cool when it
comes to like I know we also have the
stats coming back as well so you've got
intellect discipline strength should be
returning if the picture is true but
they seem to lead into that do you have
any forget who I heard even the idea
come from but ideas for Legos fireteam
chat actually builds that you think like
hey I want a lead head lean heavy into
grenades on my warlock and go like all
out on that one or are there any builds
you think that now with the new
customized stats that you might be able
to try out an experiment more because
the subclass is still gonna be the same
but do you think there's any stats that
might be able to make something more
creative either of you by the way are we
going to go for but she's like well I
gotta think hold on so if so many you
know option you know things that I can't
wait to deep that with our armor 2.0 and
you know as you know clean I mentioned
earlier I the only thing I hoard is you
know the different armor pieces that you
know have synergy with certain weapon
types and scavenger perks and things
like that so just to see how that's
handled we know intellect discipline all
that only one Styles coming back that's
introduced then to see how the new perks
that they added it's gonna be a little
bit old like like information overload I
think maybe at first so what I'm hoping
is I know we talked about prior was that
maybe a week or two you know prior to
shadow keeps launch maybe they do
something similar to how they did with
weapons 2.0 mm only we got rid of the
whole double limit you know primary
primary oh yeah and it brought it back
to d1 kind of style but a little bit of
a twist but they gave us an ability to
play with it I believe like a week or
two prior pursue them for a second yeah
yeah Forsaken to get the community use
because again we're gonna have to get
you know acclimated you know and again
what happens with the old on do it you
know it's gonna be a lot of QA going on
and I gotta figure it out and get
familiar so that that's the thing I'm
really excited about you know II we know
how you love you
PG heart yeah armor mechanics so yeah
I'm excited I'm a 2.0 I cannot wait
thanks I'm just excited I'm excited to
just see where it takes us I I don't
really I don't really have a specific
like build that I want to work towards
cuz honestly to be honest with you I
don't even know what I want to do yet I
just know the world is your oyster I
just want to be wonderful
[Laughter]
they need somebody I was like I'm sure
about 10 people but I want to see like a
bungie sure where there's like a cartoon
version of somebody saying like moons
haunted or something like that cake so
oh that would sell definitely found just
gone yeah I better hurry up and do it
because someone else is gonna do it now
that they heard it came from I was like
we've awoken the high of how many wait
the hopefully
from missions and grinding quest and
shooting stuff like oh my god the number
of times that door opened I died the
door opened
yes so that's what those things to
because they as you said when they like
redid some places on the moon they
describe right nears you would kind of
head down the stairs towards where we
awoke of the hive that look at enough
section with the little building is now
gonna be like a lost sector you can go
in and explore they revamped that one
you had the Fallen they crash the ship
so they've kind of got there now based
on the moon we're gonna be going to the
Hellmouth with the red keep that whole
thing to explore a little bit yeah I
would imagine that was gonna be helium
filaments it's only fitting that they
kind of but you know it would be nice if
like it would be nice I think one of the
things is is like like you said before
the nostalgia versus the new things you
know but sometimes it's nice to have
them go into one together so we'll see I
don't know I'm pretty excited like I'm
jumping on my skin but I can't say
itself and then we've got two things one
for me obviously I've said it before the
dungeon because I love shattered throne
it is my baby that's like my one of my
favorite pieces because I'm a solo guy
so I can't explain that and then we've
got the black garden raid so the
question is so the season is based
around vex and we have been told I think
that we're gonna be fighting vex in the
raid so I was curious if you guys had
any theories or speculation or just your
thoughts on the fact that we're going
through the moon related to hive but
somehow do you guys think they're gonna
actually still connect the raid in any
way or do you think it's gonna be here's
a raid because there's one like frame
from some duck fight like video where
there's the vex like the black garden
portal but it's in one of the moon
sections where like that somebody pulled
a frame has seen it so do you guys think
they're gonna be able to connect those
two in some way or do you guys how how
do you guys feel or do you want it
either I can go
because she's like wheeze like she's
like I I can't okay so Queen just a copy
no thoughts on this one Cognito you're
good she can't you know yeah if you
can't then don't you're good no leave I
am confident like a narrative link
between you know the going ons with the
hive and what Eris is feeling because
she's all freaking out she freaking out
stuff going on we gotta see what's going
on so you know in this threat seems very
interesting a lot of nightmares a lot
you've seen hints of returning
characters that we've already killed oh
yeah I've seen gall which excited me a
little bit I seen or it so excited to be
a little bit so I'm like okay that just
like just that alone out of his attic
but then he mentioned facts and you
mentioned you know black garden and like
you say he like this really know on face
value there's no link right but clearly
this is the direction it going so I'm
confident you know I think someone in
the chat said it um that maybe it's like
a you know how they set up dreaming city
because their first was all about
parents got it rains K kkkk avenge get
them run them down and we're thinkin
that's really kind of it yep and then
it's like talisman and then boom this
whole new world of the Rings looking
dreaming city looking fantastic that was
an amazing transition it was so well
done oh one thing I one thing I can say
that the the raid the raid is a mystery
to me so I have no idea and I have so
many theories in my head about how it's
gonna be but one thing that like when I
when you think about going back to the
black garden it automatically brings you
back to your heart spot of vault
applause I see and for me falta class
was like it was just my baby podcast
right now second now you got a second
you got some competition now you guys
alright oh man voltar so dear I have
been slandered on this podcast by my god
I gotta exaggerate don't you all the way
I'll do the bus because I'm bobbing with
Queen right and I've been holding the
flag of I've been told that all I care
about is nostalgia that it really wasn't
that good arrayed and I'm telling these
people this single activity changed the
face of death yesterday did not have
vaulted glass if there was no vault of
glass which thing this game would not be
in the same shape so I'm just so glad
you said those kind words those things
you said you know I just will let you
could I just had the interval continue
keyboard was a fun it was a phenomenal
rate it really was yeah it it was the
first of raids and that raid set tone to
all of the race after in even though
it's gotten the rates have gotten
they've gotten crazy like crazy in a
good way you know what I'm saying like
the way who the the mind behind the
creators of those raids I would love to
pick them every single day because the
the things they come up with and the
raids are just genius the mechanics all
of these things that you do in the raid
like sometimes I sit back and I think to
myself wow how did you even think about
doing this you know takes a really smart
very intelligent and just like a very
imaginative imagine Oteri's I you say
that brain so but fault up glass I had
my first experience in there and it was
a beautiful positive experience and I
think that's the reason why I fell in
love with it so much because after that
I lfg and there's the reason there's not
much making in those things stand out
give me a standout vault of glass moment
or encounter for you that kind of like
really like blew your model just changed
away oh we got to the boss we got to the
boss and you would have to go in to get
the to get the UM chill
and stuff to bring them out yes and that
that to me was just genius like his
gonna figure it out you're like where
what do I do
you know and then you sit on a plate and
it opened up and you're like oh I'll go
in here but then you realize when you go
in there you're about to get rekt you
know get to that chilled fast and pick
it up and then come on out yeah I just I
think I think that was probably one of
the ones I hated the jumping puzzle with
because I'm terrible at jumping but it
made me a better cross I think you
nailed it for me I like there's no mini
encounters but for vault for me when you
get to the the Templars is actually the
Templars is fun prior because the
Oracles are fun because I was listening
to the sound and I like that kinda stuff
fun but a pion was really cool because
again you split into teams of three and
one of the coolest things is like one
person your screen is getting you're
losing visibility and do some would like
to clean you open yeah I can see it I
get through are you splitting up with
two teams of three and then they kind of
come all back together onto the plate to
do DPS like it's like you kind of fought
through time to get to where you are and
then to come back together at that
moment is just iconic for all right so
what was your favorite raid
oh yes yeah mines I know what Lords is
was a great raid the mechanics were
beautiful I had so much fun in that raid
did I want to like like literally watch
my teammates drop off the side because
they leave all the sensor be censored
well I enjoyed I don't think there's
really a raid that I didn't enjoy other
than Spyro stars and the reason why
didn't enjoy X coz I'm bad at it
yeah I'm terrible I mean I don't think a
lot of people like that one say you're
okay
terrible
that one I'm just a terrible like there
are so many things in that raid that I'm
terrible at
like it just well I'm I don't know I
just didn't I didn't have a lot of fun
in it but also maybe it's just because
I'm bad at it like yeah Kings fall for
me it was like it was the culmination of
first time you saw her - you killed Kurt
okay you killed this guy cool okay then
you go okay his dad's pissed pop him is
like wiped out just Maura and all that
stuff and you got the taken that come in
and then you're in his ship and then you
go through the regicide mission and you
think you got him and then he stands up
in the in that stands up but he's like
like I don't know celestial God level
sizing or like there were quite a few
little clips of people seeing him for
the first time first time hilarious out
there where there's like oh those are
gay me of boss I can't tell you guys how
sassy miss sexy sparkles would get when
she go up to jump to get the to get the
pill on the top on the on the last part
and are the cleanser you the cleansing
shield can't remember what was it called
there to get it and if somebody would
hop off the plate or they mess up and
not kill something oh no that was
usually my job
yeah yeah like except it was a lot
louder than that and a lot more squeak
here no I was because like when it came
to the daughters he couldn't pick who
got it but when it came platforms like
I'm running like usually I would because
I'm like I knew it's like I could hate
it I wasn't wearing you guys know this
like I'm gonna go hit those cuz honestly
some people would be like you'd watch
him go like slow and I'm just like touch
it and tap in and I was like I was just
faster you had to be quick so I'm like
get out of the way I'm running this
thing you guys stand on your platform so
know if people got off and you're like
you're jumping it's just like they go
away you know
all right wipe it here we go it's like I
can't because if you fall like right in
the end you done so no I understand that
registration completely always got
picked which is thing it always picked
me first
ioanna one I died and let it pick
someone else before I came in there I
would I'm not kidding
all right everybody load in why is they
knew it to you
thank you you get so mad at me he's like
I don't know why she does this because
I'm not jumping like were like it was a
nightmare
yes a train is just a coil like it is is
such a hardcore experience in it's such
a challenge and it really it was just so
well done
well I I'd never concerned a king that
Kings fall when you be king full you
felt like you conquered before you
caught something the truth yeah the
truth that took time yeah so when you
you got a good at well oil team you
respect it because you know the pain
when one person convenes the mess up on
kingsville oh yeah well I mean you even
had to open the door and people were
running back and forth like you knew if
the team was gonna have a chance to like
make it work because if they couldn't
open the door before were priests you're
like see yeah yeah but not only that so
going back going back all the way to the
vault of glass one thing that I have
always enjoyed about the raids is the
different techniques and way that you
ways that you can do them you have your
people who like to speedrun you have
your people who like to do it you know
one way or a certain way or a harder way
you have people who like to solo it you
have people who like to three-minute
like one of the things that I loved
going all the way back which I mean you
didn't really hear a lot of about it
like in d1 or I didn't because I wasn't
really around twitch that much of the
solos and stuff but now soloing and
speedrunning is a really big thing and I
have a lot of friends who do the solo
and runnin and stuff
and one of the things that I love about
my community is they they they never say
anything to like I'm a I'm a do it
certainly one time a certain way next
time I start with you next time and
they're they don't care and that's one
thing that I love like they kind of just
let me do my own little things and one
of the things I've that I did take some
heat for the ribbon thing where when you
go when you have six men on one side and
you do it with the cluster bombs because
the bomb yeah and I was like so this is
this is one of the things that I have
always like not said anything about cuz
I'm like hey I don't say anything I'm
like piss off I'll do how I want
whoa the thing about it is at the end of
the day Who am I to say to someone you
can't play a game the way you want to
play it you know what I mean like you
guys play how you want to play and I'll
play how I want to play and the thing
about it is at the end of the day you're
still playing the game you know you're
still having fun and if you're having
fun that's all that matters and I I'm
just tired of hearing people complain
about other other people saying and I'm
probably gonna catch some heat for this
just being honest is good at the end of
the day have fun enjoy yourself play
your game how you want to play it you
know don't let people dictate to you how
to play your game cluster bomb she's for
the yeah I just I'm like it's in it it's
like that and it and I use driven
because ribbon is a very big thing right
now but also you have a lot of other
things that people do like when they're
trying to solo or speed run or stuff
like that like at the end of the day you
know it's a game you play with your
friends you have fun you know enjoy
yourself and don't worry about it so
that's one thing that I just I that
drops me bananas like I I hate nitpicky
stuff and I'm probably gonna get in
trouble for that one this is honestly
said the same thing on here is like yeah
whether it was people get like you know
the tension in the air before something
comes out or whatever it's like
a videogame come on like there are
always bigger problems than anything
we're dealing with in this world so
don't let it like get under your skin
and as you said like hey I want to do it
real you could always do the cheese
really shut up I want to do it how I
want to like leave me a little like and
it doesn't matter it's like if you don't
like it leave that's the thing about it
is I think I've I think I used to be
it's funny because I used to be so um I
used to be so I didn't want to like rock
the boat yeah now that I'm starting to
now I'm starting to get to the point now
to where I have people come in they're
like oh you're doing this this is my
this is my game I paint with this I want
to play how I want to play it just
drives me crazy because at the end of
the day I would never like say you guys
were streaming I would never come into
your stream and say to you why are you
doing that why do you do it like that
you should do it that way you know it
just that drives me bananas because you
guys it's your stream it's your it's
your community playing your game how you
want to play it so yeah I'm probably
gonna take some heat for that but I
really I think you talk about the
argument of um you know sometime listen
a lot of people mom over emphasized
efficiency and I get it you know there's
one things done quick and I get there's
nothing wrong with that right sometimes
some things just feel fun right doing
something a specific way or playing with
a certain load out or whatever it is and
I'm the first time like very you know
far as like the way I like to do things
I'm very specific and you know sometimes
it goes against the matter or against
that the effective strategy and I'm just
like no I like doing it this way I like
play with I like it yeah and that's the
weight like okay so there's some times
where I'll go into ribbon and the reason
armies and rivers that's a big the
reason why I go and like I'll go under
but sometimes I'm like listen let's do
eyes you know and some of the some of my
my sharpest blade we we do like we
rotate and I'll ask people if it's their
first time I'm like how do you want to
do do you want to do do you want to do
three and three
new six on one side you want a
one-in-five do you want two and four
like how do you want to do it you tell
me how you wanna do it cuz there's so
many different ways that you can do it
and the and I let them choose and then
and it at the end of the day it's about
their choice if they want to if they
want to do it three and three we do it
and but the but the thing about it is is
it's just it's crazy to me because if
I'm doing it and I'm going through and
we're like just we're just knocking out
raids trying to get our our stuff so
that we can get stuff done so while so
we can level to get to where we need to
be especially if we're getting ready for
a big raid that's coming out or
something like that we'll do everything
fast in the speed strat way so I think I
think that it's time that people start
being a little more open and a little
bit more you know hey you know what if
they want to play that way that's you
know that's their that's their decision
and play that way so but I just I I just
I really I really have started becoming
more more about voicing my opinion on
that because I just I get tired of I get
tired of that that's just so it's
negativity and you want to be positive
you know I mean honestly sometimes for
me it's like I haven't done riven nearly
as much as you it sounds like for sure
but I mean it'd be a point where it's
like I haven't done anything but the
cheese and it'd be like yes to be like
hey I want to check that box at some
point somebody be like why are you be
like because I want to it just and
there's no reason you shouldn't have
that choice you're playing a game it's
your choice and that's just it like I've
never it's really funny because outside
of destiny I've never heard anyone
really complain of any of the other game
when I play other games and stuff but
for some reason you have some people who
are like you're gonna do it the absolute
100% you know way that it's meant to be
did you know I'm like so this is me
finally standing up and saying I know we
touch on a lot and I think what I
realized
and I think there's a big deterrent even
for me sometimes in the beginning when I
started started rating was that like you
say so many people have so many specific
ways and sometimes survival rate is too
could be too many chefs in the kitchen
and to me it's like look no one likes to
be yelled it likes to be in it
no one like some people are doing it for
the first time someone too bad at worst
experience I've had it's like I don't
know what I'm doing no one's talking you
know and someone just pulled me aside
like look cop this would you can't just
stand here
do this do that we're going on that play
and then and then they're talking me
through as opposed to what you don't
know how to what oh like that's a
deterrent and that is what makes people
not rape so when I see stuff like that I
go out my way to put myself in that
position say hey I don't know what I
didn't know how to do exams a let me
pull that purse to the side and then I
love when you have stuff II like
menagerie which is what I call like gray
light that kind of stuff was really cool
to give people confidence to say you
know why after we did this menagerie you
know a little smaller mechanics yeah I
might try right now you know I'm saying
so it's really I have meted I have meted
my purpose before in the middle of raid
I've meted my stream and went off to our
stream couldn't see me and I've set
because I've had you know sometimes
Sherpas have bad days too you know and
95% of the time my Sherpas are
phenomenal mm-hmm but everybody has a
bad day and so I've muted it before him
when I'm streaming said listen mm-hmm
you need to chill you know come on down
that this is their first time being in a
raid don't do not ever make someone
else's first experience be a negative
experience when you when someone comes
in to raid with you you want them to
have a positive experience so they're
gonna come back you know and they're
gonna say they're gonna fall in love
with the game they're gonna want to
continue to play the game they're gonna
want to learn the mechanics of that rate
and teach other people mm-hmm that is
your goal make someone's day make them
have a wonderful experience
mm-hm and so yeah so I completely agree
with you on that and I think that's one
of the so going back to lfg when I used
to lfg you know I can I've got it kicked
for being a girl I've got kicked for
being a Tweaker and I'm not I've got
eight
for not knowing the mechanics I've got
kicked for knowing the mechanics and
voice in my opinion you know like you
there's so many things that that
happened to people every day when they
lfg so the community that I have one of
the things that are really pushes for
them to raid together become friends and
and and really like and then share it
outside we also do our sharpest school
to which we're doing tonight because I
want them to learn how to Serpa because
in return they're gonna go and do the
same thing and be positive to other
people and just bring more people into
rating and enjoy the game graphic to put
on stream but I'm just gonna look for a
little halo to put over your head real
quick well I mean it took me a while to
get to this point and really learn you
know I've went through my learning
curves to you I have a I have a I have
my days where sometimes I get grouchy
with my sharpest and I can be a little
sassy and stuff but for the most part I
always try to remember that you know
they're doing me a favor too they were
there to help me out and they're not
getting paid for it and they're not on
stream except for with me and they're
they're not there so I also try to shout
them out and give them love as well you
know shout out to the Sherpas who help
every single day not just me but every
channel in the community and make it a
better place that's willing to help
others yeah absolutely
oh yeah sorry I'm super excited like I
think that I think that the community is
definitely going in a more positive way
like you guys said like 'hey-- like you
said as well they're starting to they're
starting to you see a lot of positivity
in the directory now and I think people
are starting to get it that you bring
more people in with positivity and love
and you make people feel more welcome
than you do with being negative and
toxic and so I think I hope that is
starting to catch on and it just ignites
you know absolutely so one other thing
as I keep trying to slowly work us
through all this stuff but I'm enjoying
it every little
piece of our tangents so it's amazing
when it comes to other stuff that we get
to look forward to we also got some
stuff about the artifact actually just
the fact that it's actually going to be
I wanted to get you guys thoughts on the
seasonal nature of the artifact because
when we go through we're gonna have
we're gonna have the seasons obviously
have the undying and stuff like that but
now we're gonna have actually a piece of
armor tied to those seasons and I wanted
to get your guy's theory on if you like
that idea
um just the fact that you're gonna lose
at the end of a season get a new one
just kind of your thoughts on the whole
like short term piece of armor that's
probably gonna be potentially quite
important so I was just kind of curious
what you guys thought about that I like
it okay back to you lord no not such an
aspect respect the artifacts I mean you
know I don't I don't want to go I don't
wanna lean either way just until I
expect because artifacts
I had like a mixed bag like there's some
things I really like yeah I mean but
then i remember playing trials and three
guys in the back with gory and then i
remember certain was that sounded cool
but they wasn't really implemented it
was one night like we should go back
rockets or some radagast or something
yeah yeah there was like a whole bunch
of different stuff and um it listen I
got right now bungees in anywhere I can
sit there in a good place like they're
in a good place beautifully they're in
pocket they weigh from and all you know
they're doing their thing
so I'm confident that if they bring an
ant artifacts back that it will be done
in a cool way
now the only thing I'm kind of with youí
is that I don't know how I feel about
them going away at the end of a season
but I don't know like this is a checkbox
is an on/off button what happens to that
artifact but they take it out my ball
like wait wait
like she's like they're talking about
all the stuff I experienced shopping at
detective I'm listening I don't know how
I feel about that part about a season
almost like a timed armor piece like a
little weird so again hopefully the
information that guy I don't know I'm
just going over what you guys are
telling me with Queens curse that's all
I could say like why are you giving her
I'm sorry but she has been ultra
positive great today so I have such a
troll though I am i massaged Charles to
my community like last night you guys
ever listen the Patricof of son job when
he's like who Louise who I was talking
we raided last night offline me and the
mods and I was like holy girlies oh the
girlies come over here grab this all
right click over to this side and
they're like started doing it to it so
we were literally talking like Patrick I
mean we just do things like that like
shoulder to shoulder charge second off
side why is trying to get the seeds for
the skill to which and last wish I just
do things like that all the time cuz I
hate what is what is fun if you don't
troll she's the wrong I own perfect oh
do Care Bear stare in front of somebody
hilarious hilarious I think that from
what we saw so far from the artifacts
that total set up to troll that was a
total of the husband he what do you
think I hate you chirping I was going by
community feedback the halo was a pair
um like sure so we got both in there so
don't worry Narns are probably better
suited for me
if you rate it with me ah you probably
got arms the first day we did solder
arms on the ogre and last wish they
thought I was joking they were like are
you really being serious like are we
fixed and I'm like get your sidearms out
we're doing it we're gonna Boop and
we're gonna sidearm and they're like no
way this is gonna work and we killed it
and they were like oh my god like I mean
that's the fun about like I said going
back to the raids the fun about the
rates is you can use different guns you
can use crazy guns you can do silly
things and look I don't know if you guys
have saw the community thing that's
happening on Sunday mm-hmm I so it's
like routine math class all of them
ascend all of us together are getting
together some some really good content
creators we are they're doing a race
this weekend and the rules so we
basically have to we basically are it's
gonna be a nightmare so you have to you
cannot do any speedrun strats you have
to do everything like the the way that
it's meant to be but also the community
gets to vote to take away some of our
subclasses they get to vote to take away
some of our Lincoln band guns during the
reign so I think to start off every 10
minutes they can vote to take away a
subclass and again I can't I can't
remember I can't remember I think it's a
sub class like halfway through I'm not
sure how old they are
I don't want to say the wrong thing but
I know that they're going to be able to
ban subclasses and been guns and stuff
throughout the raid so the first sub
class to go that's easy Wells gone oh
it's the god like there's no way yeah
and 100% you better believe like
I see them taken away Melton point I
still own I think I'm taken away stop
your games gonna go gonna go bye-bye I
see them take I see them taking away
every every gun that we probably are I
seen them taking away shotguns Oh God
can you hold class like that damn and
and and what if they took out impulses
and you get to ribbon what are you gonna
cheat dad's with yeah I'm probably
giving them ideas that's probably really
done I'll be watching for now yeah
that's awesome yeah I saw that coming
through so that'll be something
definitely to watch and occupy your
Sunday with oh yeah and they but they
won't tell us our teams we have no idea
where we won't Noren teams until the day
of and I told them I was like don't put
me in second on the same team really if
I be him I'm gonna rub it all in his
face yeah walk you walk out of there
after you win he's still going I'm just
gonna go chill you good luck have fun
yeah but if I get beat out for something
be sassy so I know it's not a two-way
street I see how that goes I'm gonna go
in there and distract him and be like
don't you you don't see that you don't
see this look at this look look the
stream is like there seems to be an
obstruction in your view that Queen is
banned she's no longer allowed but yeah
no I mean for bringing it back to work
on the artifacts for me I guess the
biggest thing is I want them because
they said and I'm honestly thinking cuz
they said they're gonna evolve the
artifacts over time to where they kind
of get more I guess usefulness and kind
of power as they kind of get used to
what they want to do with them the nice
thing I think if they do you know
put something in this game breaking it
does go away and you know the season so
it isn't going to be something but like
hey we experiment this thing okay you
guys killed everything in the game well
in three months this will go away like
they'd at least have kind of a precedent
for a timeline but my worry is like if
you take the time I don't want the time
of investment for a three a true
temporary thing to meet you hi that's my
biggest thing is like if I'm gonna put
my time into something I mean I don't
know if it's gonna be a time gated thing
am I looking at the last part of the
season if you got a cover you're facing
and that's totally fine but for me it's
the biggest thing is that it's the time
and that's something I'm sure they
worked on bill yeah the investment
versus what you get out of it the fact
that it is a three season alone Lee is
gonna be my curious thing to watch I'm
excited about it but I definitely want
to see how that balance comes in so
that's what I'm but I mean when you I
literally the two Vidak frames I was
like Armour 2.0 I that I did a 14 minute
video over a frame of a video minute in
12 minutes over the artifact frame I'm
gone okay this is this cuz I went
through and I looked and all of those
couldn't be placeholders who knows but
there was like a warrior ability there
was like hunter there's like natural
fletching for a bow there was triple tap
I'm like how is all this stuff on there
like I don't even know how this oh I'm
like honestly like very very curious how
they work because the potential to I
mean if it's there there was relic rapid
hit was one of them I'm like yeah all my
guns get rapid it like I don't know well
if all of that stuff's gonna work that
way but I mean in theory it could be
really really interesting so I mean just
them bringing that back but actually
giving us more depth to it I'm if you
can't tell I'm an RPG nut so I'm black
between the stats and then the builds
and then the armor picking of you're
like if I yeah just the fact that the
occurrence that's we have having a wider
range and then intellect and no I just
cannot wait to see the range of what
people can make of a character cuz yeah
people are gonna come like optimal
loadouts there's gonna be a lot of them
because you're gonna do the purposes so
should be fun isn't it funny isn't it
funny how excited excited you get about
something that you know is coming out
and you're not sure like what's good
what's it going to be how is it going to
go but also on top of that
you're excited for all the new content
all the new things that's coming out and
you setup you sometimes you sit and you
strategize in your head how you think
things are gonna go but then when they
get here it's like 110 times better yeah
that's why I've even thought about like
with new light coming there's gonna be a
lot of new people so so much like
Stephens like this level of a game on
Steam for free I don't I can't think of
one at this scale polish and it doesn't
exist so like let me go play year 1
raids proper weapon systems gonna be in
there strikes cursor Bowl normal gambit
like you have all that for $0 I'm like
yeah people are gonna jump in and play
so you're gonna have a lot of
blueberries that need to learn and I'm
thinking I'm like okay so how to help
out new players but until I understand
how armor works and stuff I'm like I
can't really touch some of that until I
understand more so because yeah we need
to get our hands on some of that stuff
so yeah yeah that's kind of one of the
big ones is like the artifact piece of
it truly being a seasonal thing I was
like so interesting yeah that one
definitely has me thinking I was like
mine's just wondering right now I got a
whole month to go wreck my brain
honestly the more I think about
everything foreshadow keep the more
questions I have than answers and that's
the only I'm like hey what could maybe
ok and then there's a fall down another
rabbit hole so it's gonna it's gonna
this month is gonna fly by though I
think it's gonna fly by because I think
I think that uh especially with salsa
with solstice coming out and something
like that it's gonna give us that that
thing that we need as far as grindin and
stuff once we get this armor and
everything and our guardians are primed
and looking good and then BAM shadow
keeps gonna drop so I think this next
month is going to be yeah cuz we have it
how long do we have solstice solstice is
the 30th so Tuesday to the 27th so we
have it for 4 weeks and then from August
27th through the 17th we have 3 weeks
until shadow keep so there's a little
bit of a downs I'm kind of not sure
they're gonna fill that or if they're
gonna prep it in any way but yeah we
gotta bail yeah to wrap up the 12 I know
we've been all over the place from
tangents that everything too
but honestly it's been amazing so I
haven't cared at all so if you as you
guys know Lord of wolves is gonna get
rained in yeah cuz this working as
intended right now I haven't come across
a lot of Lord of wolves I have seen I
really have it are you on PC or console
pc as much as you think
no it's like every yeah it's not the as
bad but the occasional mother I like
come join my lobbies yeah apparently
I've just had bad luck
honestly it hasn't been too overbearing
but the point where somebody's like Lord
oiler
it's gonna be one of those games cuz you
do when somebody does have it man you do
see a lot you wanna know you want to
know how I've been countering and I know
that I know that this is probably not a
popular like I know that Scouts are not
popular among people right now but
really honestly so I've been keeping my
distance and using the Mota the other
day my community can tell you I took out
like six people and two of those people
had Lord of wolves from a from a pretty
good like from Cummins list you know
into into range but I've learned now to
kind of play back a little bit instead
of rushing in and once I get that kill
switch over tomorrow close and just go
and I beat out I beat out Lord of wolves
before with recluses when I got up
rocked so I think I think that mighta
has been making it better
mmm-hmm for me cuz I just go ahead and
pop them from a range before they can
even get close but don't get it twisted
Lord of wolves has a good range
it's got crazy range so if you get
within distance of it you're gonna get
rekt but I don't really use lord of love
so because I'm not good with it I know
that sounds crazy I know you don't but I
miss people all the time like you're
talking to somebody with a shotgun like
I'm terrible that's all you can be
saying right here and I'll shoot the
shotgun I'm shooting the ceiling all you
have to do is point at the general area
over here I don't know how I get kills
sometimes I really don't with the weight
with my aim it's terrible
well you sound
apparently kind of like I do not giving
yourself enough credit I'm sure because
talking Neto gives him that all the time
I'm like man I'm not that great at PvP
and I really am not like I'm okay I have
knives no this is one thing on Twitter I
posted because somebody even was like
somebody's like hey I see all these like
little clips and like green shots on on
Twitter like people having crazy games
and be like I don't even know if I need
to go in there and I replied nose like
it was actually out of you know I
replied and I was like dude the one time
that I can post up a cool picture
there's nine other games that follow
that one when I'm sitting in the bottom
of the barrel like shooting myself in
the toes like nah believe me like the
game I will say has late I'm like on a
yo-yo like up and down and up and down
so it's like there are good games but I
guarantee like everybody's got their
games are few and far between but I do
have some good games I mean I would say
I would consider myself an average
player like in PvP I think I think at
times I can I can do a really good job
and then at times at the bottom board
and you're like Queen what the heck you
just had 31 kills and now you have in
and he's just in his own and he's just
like man like you know you running this
town just say nothing's working more you
just have what I consider like I call a
crucible luck and it's just like alright
I got my super I just got the heavy tank
I shot oh man like you know they're like
those bad instances and it starts to
snowball and you just like oh just you
get on tilt yeah like I gotta leave I
got a [ __ ] I gotta go do something but
you get it but we're gonna get the let's
talk about the inland that working I'm
sort of looking at so are you are you
digging the Lord of wolves yeah the
laser weird the melting skull in the
folio hood that thing looks cool that
way are you gonna stay on my case it was
obnoxious right that matter
Polaris Lance laser tag yes laser tag no
and blokes are cool though they I think
the emblems are gonna
you know it's a nostalgia thing you're
gonna get the baby up would be like and
remember when we did it
yeah that's great that's that mm-hmm
yeah those two are awesome so yeah if
you've been playing in the last couple
iron banners you're gonna get the Wolves
Unleashed
and then if you played during the crazy
laser tag which shout out to Steve
attack on Twitter cuz I was literally
like oh I don't know if I got it he like
checked my like games from old and was
like yeah you're good it was like I'm
sitting I work I'm like thanks so like
that's awesome
I was like somebody checked it for me
I'm like I didn't even know you can look
at my stuff I'm kind of worried about my
security right now but thank you
[Laughter]
honestly like that that alum emblem like
almost doesn't fit in the game but I
love it so much because it's like it's a
melting skull and laser beam and
somebody's like like you wouldn't know
if you were there but like everybody who
doesn't have it is gonna be like where
did that come from and like but yeah mom
Tuesday we've got the patch come in two
point five point two Lord of wolfs so
let me see what you guys think about
these changes we've got reduce the
amount of ammo shotgun scavenger perks
can give to Lord of wolves win in
releasable of state which there is a way
to get around that depending on how you
run around and pick up ammo decreasing
the effective range on Lord of wolves in
general and even more so when released
the wolves is active so do you guys
think that will kind of reel it in do
you think that'll be enough I think
it'll really then I think I honestly
think with good honestly think with
anyways Cognito what about you sir it's
not gonna matter alright I mean you know
as much as I you know have my issues
another one of my favorite exotics but
it needed a broken exotics yeah I mean
it was for the fact that you could
activate the released I'll perk at will
you know I'm saying there's gonna be a
lot of people happy I think you're gonna
be happy once it once that's done I
think
I think it'll make it better I really do
so yeah bring the range down you know
that that to be thing there the ammo
count on the scavenger perks obviously
are some people trying to get around my
hat holding a lot that's gonna bring it
down and the decrease is bought pressive
when it's far as the range when the
release the Wolves stays up because
that's the thing I mean the thing it was
just sometimes it was getting too baby
pulse rifle range and you liked it was
yeah daddy should we get it before it
does any yeah you know so it had to
happen I'm not too upset with this one
me neither
attribute hall they get a couple of
fixes iron banner next time just gonna
have a couple of those quest steps
lowered mainly the grenade kills which
is everybody's like stubbing their toe
on to be like how many do I have
it's a nightmare oh no 100% believe it
yeah yes I mean I'm on III refuse to do
it
I mean on my hunter I'm trying to think
I don't even know what percentage of on
but I'm sure it's trash right now
because I've been playing on my own or
surprisingly but yeah I think that one's
definitely slow on my Titan it seemed
better because pulses and control work
pretty well cuz people be kind of
clumped and you get a couple kind of
collateral generally be a hunters I've
been I've been so focused on a whole
different build buddy I'm so class bias
or hate that friggin thing oh no listen
when that's supernova thing that
handheld Supra never hits me I literally
stop and look at the camera and I'm like
give my hunt or something like that
god be the hunters you have this one I
got a show I have a shoulder charge
shoulder charge that is the blood man
but I will definitely say that handheld
supernova goes like blue like through
the aired sube yeah like oh and it's
farther than I can shoulder turns I'll
tell you that
I'm freaking hated but ya know hunters
the worst yeah oh oh but you got blade
rush you can kiss my butt
you guys don't you know you guys don't
have to use your first to use your
things to get a one-shot kill
I gotta get one shot or no it was the
new uppercut no no I have to stab twice
to kill mmm oh yeah and if you're not
750 I've had to punch three times so so
be high and level and iron banner cuz
I'm like why am i three punch and these
people why for why am I getting off
three and winning that's stage one but
two yeah I'm like oh yeah that's my out
of seven forty I was like I got to 746
and it was like to ten but I was like
punching remember back in the day and d1
when we relax for just one shot melee
the next guest Class B little tight love
in here even like polls I see out there
Billy
hey best sub class like warlock or
hunter I'm like Titans guys where you at
and everybody's just lay even like what
does it data puts out a video or
somebody's like Titans are weak and I'm
like they have some purpose with your
Sentinel shield now but it's like I'm
gonna hold my right mouse button and
just do this for a while you guys good
back there alright cool back here
[Music]
yeah we could do things with that try to
kill them in that super sometimes when
they hold that shield out and I'm trying
to kill them like mr Turner and it gets
me so mad
I've been I've been bamboozled a couple
of times with a person who's a really
good Titan mean with that shield yeah
yeah I will say like it bugs the hell
out of me for a couple things like when
I'm like literally throwing a hammer and
it's like this far away from you and
then all of a sudden gyro your super can
take a hammer but I can't take one of
your blades or
I'm like I have to hit you twice and I'm
so like okay giving taking balance on
stuff so it's a panic shutdown soup as
much as baby Roger being nauseous golden
on one shot see from across the deal
dude and now you can go like Bam Bam Bam
Bam you're tight and smashed and it just
shuts you down and you know somebody
Warlocks needed I mean what country
hunters hunters definitely listen well I
mean I have to me I'm like welcome to
the club I'm like yeah I miss all the
time so like the blade barrage is a good
thing to like you know to be able to
shut something down but I really like
spectral blades I mean I know that they
just got nerves and it was probably
pretty rough before but I really really
really liked Spectrals I think they're I
think they're kind of fun it's a good
place peace we've got and I actually
kind of want to get your thoughts on the
overall menagerie their heroic menagerie
will now drop a sword for your first
completion a hundred percent of the time
and in subsidy subsequent completions
will have a moderate chance about 25%
for a sword to drop on future heroics so
definitely giving a higher chance on the
menagerie heroics but I want to get your
thoughts on just basically the chess
glitch fix since I haven't actually had
a chance to pick your brain on that one
since it was fairly recent you like it
where do you think it should be if you
don't like it thoughts so I kind of saw
I kind of saw something on Twitter the
other day where someone had mentioned
about having a couple more tests
throughout the menagerie even if they
you know like just to have a couple
words or something like that as you're
going through so I I really did like the
fact that you could farm the menagerie
and in kind of farm for your roles and
stuff I think it kept people coming back
now I think a lot of people have backed
off from it because because you only
have the one chance to get the one loot
at the end so I'm thinking that maybe if
they were to add like one or two more
chests in there and give you a little
bit more of a chance to get things
because the menagerie
even though it can be a short
it can be a short challenge with your
friends if you have going there with a
team it can also be a really long
challenge if you're queuing in yeah with
someone who is not who are not your
teammates because you don't really know
how they're playing or how they play so
maybe like maybe a maybe like another
test like something else to like give
you like halfway through just to kind of
give you a little bit of a more loot or
a little better chance but I mean I
understand why they fix the glitch I get
that part I understand you know maybe if
they would have shortened the time just
a little bit or said hey you still can
farm but you're gonna have to farm you
know going through a little bit more of
these other these other techniques to to
get more chests I don't know I don't
know maybe put two chests at the end
heck I have no idea I think that I don't
like the fact that it's just one chest
in the end right I don't like that and I
think that's what made people kind of
detour away from it so especially your
PvP guys when your PvP guys are going in
there they're trying to farm there to
get their rope stuff like that
I think that opened the door for a lot
of them because I noticed a lot of the
PPP community so you doing PvE when
Menagerie came out because they were
like oh gosh I'm gonna farm for these
guns so I think that was a big bridge
for the pvp and PVE community because
they were like ooh hey you know so I
think I think I add another chest in
there would probably go a long way or
two and then shout-out to say under age
met him at Guardian con 2 and listen to
his little tidbit on it in his basically
and I was like I just kind of want to
reiterate it because you're in the same
place it's been the generosity and there
was keeping more people involved that
means you've also got I mean you've got
a range of spectrum of skill in any
activity but the more people in there is
also gonna have more of your the people
farming that thing going for the crazy
roles or matchmaking like say they take
two or three of their friends but they
match match match make with like
blueberries and pull them through and
have give them easier time and they're
like hey what's going on and it just
like it was
helping a lot of people in different
levels like some we're just trying to
finish it
some were farming for weapons sometimes
I just want to go for a couple of runs
and it was just the Jim plate overall
the generosity across the board was a
good thing and I think really hurt like
just that whole activity because now the
people who farmed enough and they're
like well ok I farmed enough I got what
I need now you go in there and you're
against the people who are like I just
got shadowy opulence yesterday how's
this work and then it's a different
group that you're playing with down
people just like it's like it's harder
cuz like the higher school may not be in
there as much because they're done they
just checked out or maybe like I saw
something in chat which as far made a
very good point um maybe if they maybe
if they made the challenges a little bit
harder and maybe had a chest after each
challenge but only certain loot in each
chest you know or something like that
yes you could farm through and get I
don't know it's I think that there is a
couple of different ways that they can
do things but uh but i think i think
you're right i think the menagerie is
gonna get harder because there's a lot
of newer people who are going to come in
there they don't really know what
they're doing and they it's it's just
it's it's harder but right now i think
if they were to add more chests i think
i think it would be yeah i think they
would come back and said if you'd like
on normal now since people a little
higher levels say you finish a each
encounter you finish within the time
limit could add a chest on top as well
yes I liked and I like rewarding skill
you doing well you kind of succeed in
the activity bonus like that would be if
it's dramatically wood with the
menagerie calluses he's challenging you
during the entire thing he's like you
know callus demands me so when that goes
down if you get that reward for doing a
section within that time limit at such a
high efficiency
you should be reversed I agree I think
when you're on something definitely a
way they can handle it yeah kudos
inspire cuz he just actually just well
yeah and chat and I was like I was like
actually that's a really good idea and
that's one thing I think for a lot of
the stuff and then what all that all
that does sadly is those like when you
go in a manager you can still pick I
want to go for an Austrian earth range
that's a still a very specific grind you
can get like 50
and still not get the role you want but
you can at least go for that weapon and
then you go look at things like blind
well which doesn't have that much
escalation protocol sometimes which is
better by the way that one's been fixed
a little more reckoning which is so bad
on drops right now like it like the
change of this has made like thinking
about other activities be like well do I
want to go run a night foam like I don't
even know if I'm going to get it I'm not
getting random rules like the rewards
throughout the whole game right now I
would like kind of come a little more
into the forefront of my mind after
saying like the change in this because
this still being like the best direct
path to anything makes everything else
even worse when this wasn't around so
yeah right no I really I think the loot
needs to be a little different in a lot
of different areas in the reckoning I
think it needs to be different anything
it needs to be turned up a little bit
for a little bit more farming a little
bit more prosperous in there I also
think that the menagerie does need a
couple of chests you know or if you do
about time and you can do it spawns two
chests at the end depending upon how how
fast or how good of a player you are I
know I I think back in d1 like when you
did the night falls the night falls were
really really hard right maybe when to
orbit if you didn't if you couldn't but
at the end it made the rewards like that
much sweeter because when you got them
and that exotic popped up you're like oh
my god
so worth it like you forgot all about
the struggle of doing it I think at the
end of the day every player in destiny
wants a challenge and they want the
reward that goes with it a me for one
like I for one I've worked on solo shot
our throne and stuff like that and I I I
love I love to do some things like that
but offline because it makes me range
offline but also you know give them
something cool for it so I agree with
you go
I think there's to be what's up Carolina
how you doing sir oh man shout-out
worlds
oh man he's absolutely sweetheart
sweetheart - he's like yeah I got to
play with him a little bit he was nice
enough to basically make some space in a
backpack for some con no ultra nice guy
thank you for coming in sir yeah he's
everything like shout out absolution
so yeah that was kind of thing with me
and shattered thrown solo like for death
nearly broke me play he like he was so
so many easy ways to die in there and as
a solo you start the whole damn thing
over yeah but even recently and then
like cognate I did a video I was trying
to do high roller it's the tribute where
you have to do all minute all menagerie
or Calla stuff and it's the hundred cane
at nightfall
mmm-hmm so it limited my Lotus that ki
could go use in a nightfall and I've run
will of thousands Sola before that's
literally what I do a solo night falls
but I have no idea why that one broke me
it was like over the course of a couple
days it was like I don't I was like
eight hours because I had to use like I
had to use basically solar stuff I
didn't have the new shotgun but even
then if I'm going for points and like
time and everything I have there was a
video out there that I did and it was
like the emotions of a solo player and
it was like basically the seven stages
of grief we went through denial
bargaining I went through all of those
in the video and there's one when it was
just like anger and I was like son of it
I'm sorry not the curse I keep it clean
but it was all of those pieces like and
everybody like whether it's Carolina
game are going for a crazy raid or if
you're working on shattered thrown off
line and you're trying to not rage but
we all go through those things and he
just said that challenge when you go
through and it kind of hurt me a little
bit when you go through solo flawless
shattered thrown its Syrian the triumph
is seriously never again but it's worth
zero points something about that just
kind of hurts my soul a little bit I'm
just like come on
so yeah that's gonna be a fun one too of
200,000 nightfall for the master work on
solace is gonna be ax yeah isn't it
funny isn't it funny how we how we have
how we've gotten like progressed on the
whole solo thing how solo has become
pretty big now it's pretty big pretty
big thing in the game and
I do agree with you it see I think
that's where things have changed like
the game has evolved and the players
have a you know we've gotten we've
gotten better and much better at the
game and there's some really good
players out there that do some crazy
phenomenal things never do you want to
Carolina's like co-pilots yeah esoteric
man oh I watched him just make me look
like just shamefully bad play oh man
so I mean the game is evolved we've
evolved and it's it's it's just getting
better I think it's cool I think it's
cool to watch people do some of the
things they do and it's very interesting
to see the strats they come up with and
I just I'm blown away by the gameplay
that I watch every day both on and off
switch on YouTube as well at some of the
people who can do it yeah it's
absolutely phenomenal
yeah and today by the way we are we are
doing a a stream today there is a friend
of ours that is this person has been a
pillar of the community and helps so
many people especially a lot of the
streamers out as well
and today we are doing a surprise stream
for the person to give back and help
them out as well so I'm looking forward
to today today is probably like today's
probably like on a scale from one to ten
I'm a nine and a half on Justin today
you just cut out there for a second nine
and a half that's how excited I am for
this person today awesome nice what time
quick I think right after this we have a
little I was like we have we are at two
and a half already I know the guy on the
other side of it needs to go for some
sleep
will awake energy like the topics in the
passion and yes very night so when I
hear that type of juicy destiny
conversations that gets the blood
flowing running my mouth appreciative I
am for you guys to like even asked me to
come on like I really appreciate you
guys have made it so unbelievably just
easy and fun and uh thank you so much
for everything that you guys have done I
am so excited that my community got to
come and watch you guys I'm sure a lot
of them will turn you're very
entertaining and you guys are super
awesome dudes
thank you we're so appreciative that you
could want as well yes it's been an
absolute blast like thank you the
pleasure has been ours for sure you've
had fun but believe me we appreciate it
and all you're obviously you brought
your stream team with you and they have
been blowing up chat so chat shadow to
everyone I definitely can't mention all
the names for sure you guys have been so
so awesome confers peace human most of
the time yeah but yeah like honestly I
don't have too much else for the day I
mean there's patching notes and stuff
but the big thing we got solstice next
week but yeah a lot of the grindage do
and a lot to look forward to but we are
over two and a half so i kind of want to
let this wrap up since i know everybody
has stuff they got to do so queen for
you first tell everybody as you said
what you got going on where they can
find you and half of these people know
where you are anyway but just let him
know because i'll put this out in lots
of places so they can definitely spread
the word and more people can find you
that's awesome first of all you can find
me doing anything with my string team
stream team is amazing shout out to them
absolutely phenomenal stream team i
can't say enough about them also you can
find me on twitter underneath red queen
twitch red queen and instagram queen but
we are we do a lot of we do a lot of
crazy we do great help we do all kinds
of things i'm super excited for today we
do a lot of really kind things for the
community as well so today is just one
of those things
where
a lot of us got together and we're gonna
help in need so I um that's what I enjoy
doing
I enjoy making people smile and helping
out people who need it if you knew a
smile on your day please check out the
Red Queen she will definitely give you
smiles and positivity here in your life
and remind you the world still has some
good and she's definitely a big part of
that so come Cognito what about you sir
I mean let him know everybody in chat
find this man tell him where they can
find it before I do that shout out again
salute to the Queen for coming your
proper respects you know like I said she
was a woman of her word
you know when we saw her and she she
said she's gonna come on she was on it
and we just honored to have her like I
said I couldn't believe two-and-a-half
flew by to be honest it was just so much
fun and just hearing the stories here
and you know her journey a list of
positivity that she breaks the community
I mean it cannot be understated I mean
enough because I mean overstate enough
because it's just like we need more of
it you know we need more of what helping
each other out and just doing positive
things so it's always good to see her
energy or sassiness to the Queen this
was phenomenal and definite look forward
to you coming back hopefully in the
future as well
brought up yeah it's just good old noah
Cognito Here I am Lord podcast you know
me look I didn't want to turn everything
on or podcast on YouTube every Sunday is
the Lord's Day we will have the Nintendo
guru on this Sunday 1:00 p.m. so check
us out he will be talk everything that's
going on within tender will also be
PlayStation Xbox ok but um yeah we'll be
talking about a lot of stuff that's
going on that came out and the rest of
the King Lord Lord sovereign got some
good stuff up and if you get a chance
please check out Lords of gaming net I
try to put some articles up there it's a
cool old that's the article right now
from yours truly about what's going on
with solstice and the the second nerfing
of Lord of wolves have some things to
say about that so please check that fix
your face a I see your face when I talk
about Lord of wolves big butt oh yeah be
please check it out loads gave me that
nap I love podcasts on YouTube Twitter
Cognito so and I really appreciated
support it's been really really cool and
of course the last word podcast every
Friday 9:00 a.m. where the cheetah and
the ninja get together by the campfire
[Laughter]
chat has been phenomenal thank you guys
this has been a fantastic show mines
quick it easy it's advances everywhere
so if you find a cheetah and ebon test
eb o and t is you'll find me so whether
it's making solar nightfall guides or
whatever else or bashing my head against
the mountaintop grind which is my
current task so i am one of those toxic
players by the way of running three
grenade launchers on pc so you see and
it's happening it's militias birthright
I don't even have a great role fighting
lion I'm getting better and then when I
see you dumped getting better I had one
and that's like the the ups and downs I
had one game where I was the top of the
leaderboard with that load out and I was
like happened and then the next one I
was at the bottom so just sliding the
heavy exactly absolutely no shame zero
shame
I was like oh there's the heavy his name
oh there he goes right he's calling
Isaac heavy in five I got my kills
I need the medals I need you guys to
come play with me one day let's rate or
play some PvP or everyone is you I would
love to have you guys come play with me
I think community would probably go
bananas Oh that'd be awesome
I'm down we won't combine forces and see
how crazy we can make it so well we will
definitely be you are welcome anytime so
we will look forward to having you back
sometime down the road because this was
way too much fun but we always wrap it
up in style joys of delays of the
internet this is always kind of hard to
time but we always kind of wrap it up by
say and like say thank you guys say the
episode number and it has been and then
all together we translate the last word
and that's where we cut it
but timings always tough so I will try
and match you guys but thank you all in
chat it's been amazing averaging like 50
of you guys in here thank you
Queens chat all of your coming this has
been amazing today so thank you very
very much and this is episode 67 July 26
and it has been the last last word